Was Jamie here the last time I
was here or was that, oh, okay.
It's remarkable. In many experience.
Joe Rogan podcast by night
darkness.
That's Jamie. We're talking
about antiquarian. Welcome.
Like from here,
she brought Mr Ana Kasparian,
the boyfriend's here. So all you all, you
sad dude's at home, don't like Eh. No,
no, no. It's never gonna happen. Now
she's got a boyfriend. She's here.
Were boozing it up too.
Well, he's gotta be on his a game
at all times because I don't know,
maybe it could have
terrible way to start a podcast.
He's amazing. He is amazing.
He's wearing pajamas, nighttime.
Just give a fuck. I like it.
Plus it's Cuban. I've got a big respect
for Cubans. So, uh, yeah, we're,
we're back with Cuba,
right?
Isn't that the new thing that's going
to be able to go over and get some nice
cigars now?
Yeah. No, Congress needs
to get involved. Right.
And Obama can't unilaterally
lift the embargo.
But I think that overall
this is good news.
And I know that there are Cubans in Miami
that her against this and they think
it's a terrible idea.
But look,
the embargo lasted 52 years
and it didn't end communism.
It just strengthened the Castro regime so
well made things really weird.
You ever look at those photos of Cuba
and you see the 1950s cars that they
evolve fixed up.
It's kind of fascinating.
It really is. I mean, when you can't
import vehicles from the United States,
you know, you gotta keep up
with the vehicles that you have.
So they are in perfect,
impeccable condition.
It's crazy.
It's weird to watch like you see like a
red light and as these photos of these
cars into like beautiful, like classic
cars that are all in great shape,
you know,
and makes you realize like we're kind
of trapped in this cycle of constantly
getting new shit, constantly getting
the, oh it's a 2016 Lexus, you know,
we get so excited about the
new one or the new ones.
Headlights move when you move like,
Oh fucking Christ.
Like we could get by with these 1950s
cars and we really wanted to set the brake
suck in the suspension sucks.
Look,
I'm not an expert in cars at all,
but I will say that the vehicles that
are being built now won't last as long as
the cars that were built in like the
1950s like do you think a car that was
built in 19 I'm sorry,
2014 is going to last 40
years or even a few decades.
I wonder,
I don't know.
I don't know enough to say whether
or not they're really built better.
I just think they were,
there's a weird thing that happened
between like 1960 and then into the 1970s
and eighties where cars just sucked.
And like in the 1960s like between like
1964 65 like the old Corvettes and going
into like the muscle cars are the classic
1967 Camaro's of those kinds of cars.
Those are some of the best looking cars
human beings have ever figured out.
And they had this weird sort of like
flair to them that you just don't get from
cars that came from the 90s. Like
those cars look like shit. Like I was,
we were watching this auction
once and uh, they had, uh,
we talked about on the podcast,
don't worry about the Camaro that was for
sale and they had a Camaro for several
year, 2002 Camaro and everybody's
like, kit, that fucking
piece of Shit Outta here.
Nobody cares about a 12 year
old Camaro kid out of here. Wow.
But like a 30, 40 year old Camaro
is that shit. Yup. You know,
so somehow or another we like,
we,
we entered into this era where people
don't want to fix those things up.
You just want to get rid of them. Like
there's like pockets where people like,
you know, you don't fix up a 2002
Camaro. Get rid of that fucking, yeah.
Thanks. Yeah. That's so true. Um,
there was a neighbor I had that
had this amazing Red Mustang.
I don't know which year it was,
but it was just such a beautifully crafted
vehicle and I compared that classic
car to the mustangs that
are being built today.
And I felt like there was no comparison.
There was something sexy about that car.
And the mustangs are sexy today too,
but not to the same extent.
Do you know it has like the curves of a
woman almost when you look at a Mustang
from decades ago.
Yeah. So they figured something
out. Yeah. I don't know what it is,
but they figured something out from like
in the 1960s where they figured out how
to make these cars just like, whoa. You
look at them. This is just classic shape.
Yeah.
I think that's coming back though.
I think the last few
generations of American cars,
they've really figured out like some
of the new Cadillacs are beautiful.
They really are incredible. So
I recently leased a new car, um,
and I settled on a BMW and it's a
great car. It's a little three series.
Um,
I really wanted like a white exterior
with red interior cause I'm an Armenian.
But um, it's in the blood. Yeah, it is.
It's in the blood. We like flashy shit.
So it was funny because I
remember talking to Christian,
my boyfriend about possibly
getting a Cadillac and he was like,
yeah,
it kind of locks are cool.
But they still kind of have like the old
man stigma attached to them even though
they're beautiful.
Yeah, they do a little bit. Right. Yeah.
Even though the new ones that are
spaceshipy, they still have that thing.
It's like for the longest
time that's what they were.
Yeah. But I really have no room
to talk before I got the BMW,
I was driving a Lincoln. Those are very
old manner as they got his old man.
I loved that car.
It was an Mkz hybrid.
It wasn't like a hip car,
but it was smooth. Right.
They've adjusted,
you know,
American cars over the last
few years have really adjusted.
Especially it seems like,
especially since, um,
they got all that money to
sort of rebuild, you know,
there was like a lot of restructuring
and it just seems like they came out with
some pretty exciting cars,
like some really nice cars now.
Well, they had no choice
after that bailout. You better
fucking deliver. I mean,
yeah. Yeah. David made the, in the world
of muscle cars, they've made amazing,
amazing cars.
They have a new Camaro out,
z 28 that is like essentially you
could buy a race car from the,
from the Chevy dealership. I mean
it's, it's a real car. It's got
500 plus horsepower. It doesn't even have
a radio. It has a speaker on the door.
It doesn't have air conditioning.
It's at this ridiculously,
they wanted to make it as light
as possible. Right. Of course.
Light battery and it's, you
know, but it's insanely like,
like capable,
like for a car that you can just buy.
I mean this thing can run on a track.
It pulls like more than one g of its own
bodyweight sideways and it's a Camaro.
Yeah. That, that's impressive.
But I always wonder about
people who buy cars like that.
Like are you really going to
take it to a track? Probably not.
Are you going to drag race it?
You probably shouldn't.
Probably shouldn't, but yeah, even
if you're driving legal speeds,
those cars are way more fun than
regular cars. Yeah, definitely.
Even if you're just
getting onto the highway,
just that a moment of
acceleration to merge and
you don't have that in
like a Honda or in a volt.
So I shouldn't,
yeah,
I shouldn't be admitting this because
it's probably not a good idea on the road.
But I have like a little bit of road
rage and my least favorite thing on the
planet is when I want to be respectful,
I want to follow the rules and I put
my turn signal on and I want to switch
lanes. Right. And the motherfucker
behind me sees that. I put, sorry,
I put the,
I put the turn signal on or whatever and
he or she starts speeding up so I won't
be able to pass. Right.
And with the Lincoln,
I wasn't able to speed up
enough to like cut them off.
But now at the BMW I'm like,
Oh, you're going to speed up.
Well then I'm going to cut your ass off.
I love it. It's such a good feeling.
That's so ridiculous. Why
don't, why don't we do that?
Do you catch yourself doing that?
Like accelerating and then just go,
why am I getting involved getting involved
in this? No, no, I never had a war.
I go to war.
That's so crazy.
Don't you think it would be like healthier
for all involved if you just like,
just let,
let this motherfucker,
you do what would be healthy if we all
respect one another's opinions without
getting outraged. If we
were more compassionate and
empathetic, but we're not,
we're animals and we're hateful
and we're not inherently kind.
Don't you think that that's not universal
though? I know a lot of people who are,
don't,
you know a lot of people who are,
I know people who are kind and I think
it's of course a mix of nature and
nurture. Right, right. I don't know.
It's funny because I was having
this conversation on um, the point,
which is one of the shows I host for
TYT network. And I said, you know,
doing this job,
and especially this year I started
feeling a little more depressed and it was
because I started realizing that there
are a lot of really bad people out there.
You're exposed to it on a regular basis
through the news stories that you cover
through the emails you get through the
tweets that you read through the comments
that you see. And it's discouraging.
It's disheartening. And I'm trying,
I'm like in a Rut right now.
I'm trying to rise above it and
not let it get to me. But you know,
you hear the police brutality
stories, you hear the, you know,
the cases where people get shot and
killed and there is no justice for them.
You read how people will be supportive
of those types of behaviors. You're like,
what world am I living in?
You know?
Yeah. It's very challenging.
Uh, you're, you're dealing
with insane numbers. I mean,
that's one of the parts of the world
that's so hard to handle and manage and in
this day and age,
so you're dealing with the influence of
billions of people literally now. I mean,
there's,
there's so much news and there's so many
stories that just the sheer numbers of
human beings and then extreme poverty,
extreme disparity and how much people
have and how much advantage they've had
been born in certain situations.
The resentment of that ramp and crime
in your neighborhood growing up in these
neighborhoods.
I mean,
there's just so many people and so many
people that just have a shit roll of the
dice. They just got a shit life, you know,
and you have to be aware of that and you
kind of have to understand where people
are coming from when they're,
you know,
not necessarily the best people on the
planet, but at the same time, look,
the Internet just exposes you to things
that are way outside your bubble. Right?
So I remember when we covered the
whole ray rice story, um, and you know,
we saw that surveillance footage of him
knocking his fiance out with one punch.
You know, of course we condemn the
action. And a lot of people were like,
what do you mean? What do you mean
you'd, she was, she was mouthing off you.
Did you see what she was doing?
She was charging at him.
And it's like ray rice is a freaking
football player, is much larger than her.
I mean, she can't really do much
damage to him. Right. And so I get the,
I get the argument that, oh,
if someone's attacking you,
you should be able to defend yourself,
but you should also know your own
strength. Right? So we make that argument.
We got so much hate on
those ray rice videos.
It was amazing and I couldn't understand
it and I still don't understand it.
Yeah, that's hard. You know, I
grew up, when I was a little kid,
I saw my dad hit my mom and my mom
moved out like immediately afterwards.
And I'll never forget it.
I'll never forget like seeing
that and it's, it's uh,
there's a big difference.
It's like a little kid trying to kick
your ass and so you need him in the face
and knock them unconscious. Like you
wouldn't do that with a little kid. Right.
You'd hold them off. Well, if it's
a woman and you're a 230 pound,
240 pounds super athlete,
I mean a fucking super athlete.
He received that guy
run like Jesus Christ.
I haven't seen him run, but I've seen
him knock someone out. The single
it was,
was a nice left hook.
Actually he had good technique like the
way through it and really knows how to
throw a punch because
it was in a short range.
A lot of guys would have wound up too
much and they would have never landed it
from, from that position. So as an
analyst it was a very good punt,
but it was rude as fuck that he did that
when she just kind of slapped him in
his head he shouldn't have.
The other thing is,
this is what people don't
like to talk about, but it's,
it's a reality is that guys who've
experienced a lot of head trauma or way
quicker to pull the trigger,
the weight quicker to
react a very impulsive
way. I love that you brought
that up because while we
were discussing that story,
I brought up the potential of all of
the head trauma leading to more violent
behavior and look, I'm not a
neuroscientist. I don't know.
That was just my speculation,
but I think that it's a pretty
good hypothesis that I'd want,
I'd want to look into a little further.
But yeah,
real real sports thing on
it recently. No, I haven't.
Yeah, they did a piece on it
or they were talking about, um,
people who were like really kindhearted
and normal and very peaceful.
And then once he started playing
football and they experienced a few head
injuries, their personality shifted and
they became like really angry and really
aggressive and really just,
and a lot of people think that
it has to do with depression,
which is like super common as well for
the guys who experienced some significant
head trauma.
And at this depression might make these
guys like more quick to snap or more
angry or more impulsive.
And that's a lot of,
that's just related to head
trauma. And that's, that's a,
that's a scary reality
that comes with football.
Yeah, I look, I wouldn't be surprised
at, look, I don't watch much UFC stuff.
Actually. I don't watch any, I'm not
going to lie to you, but I know, I know.
But is there a head trauma
involved with that as well? I mean,
you're using your full body
to beat the shit out of
someone. No, no, no, of course.
That's the point.
So were you ever surround about that?
Well,
I think for the athletes it's um,
it's a risk that pretty much
everyone is aware of at this point.
And many of them,
I think they impose like a
threshold they impose themselves.
Like if I get knocked out too many times,
if I feel like it's happening too much,
but I feel like I can't take a
punch anymore, I'm going to get out.
And a lot of guys have done this and done
this like really intelligently and uh,
made speeches about it and you know,
put a blog entries about it.
But it's a common theme
is that these fighters,
they realize at a certain point in
time they're not durable anymore.
They get hit and they get
hurt really bad really easily.
And then they start really being worried.
And that's smart.
The smart thing to do is to get out then.
But unfortunately you can't tell
someone when they can and can't compete.
So some guys, they stay too
long and they have those two,
three fights that they probably shouldn't
have had. And those are hard, hard
to watch. Well, you know,
we had this discussion about whether or
not in let's say a few decades football
will be outlawed because of
the head trauma that a lot
of these players in door.
And you know,
my argument to that would be,
it's not always the answer to ban
things, right? So for instance,
banning marijuana didn't work.
Banning drugs didn't work. Right?
But one thing that you
could do is actually educate
people as much as possible
about,
you know,
the consequences of doing such things
and then they can make an educated
decision about it with the NFL,
the NFL withheld records and studies
from its players so they wouldn't know
about what this head trauma
would do to them in the long run.
And so if I were like a
legislator or something,
I wouldn't advocate for banning
certain sports. But I would say, look,
there needs to be more transparency.
There needs to be more education.
That way people can make
a decision for themselves.
Now it's Kinda hard to do that when
you're 18 and you've been drafted out of
high school. But you know, nonetheless,
I feel like more education is the best
way to handle a situation like that.
Well, I think because of the data
that's in now, I think it's undeniable,
but I think for a long time it was one
of those things like when cigarettes
first became illegal,
you know,
there was like a lot of resistance
to make it not illegal rather.
But when the cigarettes, uh, became, uh,
like responsible for cancer,
when they became like responsible and
started having to pay out payments and
having to uh, like did
tobacco, I mean how much,
how much money of tobacco companies
had to pay out in these giant lawsuit.
It's like billions and
billions of dollars,
but they're still making so
much money that it's, it's,
it's viable for them
to stay in production.
But at one point in time they were
completely denying that there is there any
link between cigarettes and
cancer. Amazing. They were,
they were literally getting doctors
to prescribe cigarettes. I mean,
that was like a common
prescription for like wheat kids.
They had prescribed that little
fucker cigarettes. Right.
I mean,
similar things are happening right now.
Similar things or harming children,
but like guys in their twenties right?
Similar things are happening right now
with pharmaceutical companies and some of
these prescription drugs,
I mean,
things that are being marketed as
harmless are being pushed on kids that
shouldn't be taking pharmaceutical
drugs right now. It's amazing.
Yeah,
it is amazing.
And I think that when the f the football
players have all demonstrated this
consistent pattern of brain
trauma, you know, if they,
they kid each other all the time and
they're trying to figure out how to
mitigate that. But along the
way, the data becomes undeniable.
So now they're at that same
spot where they're like,
the tobacco companies were okay,
cigarettes cause cancer,
but we still want it to be
legal, you know? Okay, okay.
Football causes brain damage,
but we still want to play it.
Do you guys still want to play football?
Who wants to make money? Right?
You make money, right? You worried about
getting hit and had a couple of times,
okay, we're going to do our
best to not hit heads together,
but we're playing fucking football because
women are Americans. Yeah. Yeah. Right.
That's what happens and dudes
will fucking march out there, bro.
I'll fucking keep banging heads.
I'll still bang heads.
I'm going to fucking bang heads and
get penalised. Yeah, we're animals.
We're savages.
Especially like when you
are just a complete stud
athlete and you're involved in
this ultra competitive world of try to
dominate other stud athletes and spike
balls in their face and
they're just fucking out there.
Yeah, going to play. I got to
admit, I just visualize a stew,
super stud athletes spiking the ball
and I got a little turned off so I can
understand why they do it.
I can understand you imagine that's,
you see what?
I don't watch much football
but I love highlight reels.
I love watching ESPN because they'll
show like the best shit. I don't have
time. I don't understand the downs. I
really don't. I don't even know the rules.
I don't know the rules of football.
Neither do I. So we're on the same boat.
Who's you're calling flags? I'm
like, what is all this rest?
Why is everybody resting?
That should be just constant chaos.
I would want to see it like an MMA
bout. This is too fucking, yeah.
Five guys on this side. Five guys in
that side moved the ball, go chaos.
Craziness. No breaks. Yeah.
When you get it across,
you fucking march it back the other
way and do it that way. And no breaks,
no breaks, no this whistle blowing. And
that white guy off the fucking field,
a little tiny white guy with the white
outfit, he's going to get killed.
So he's going to accidentally run over
that fucker and he's going to die.
300 pound men on who knows God.
What kind of concoctions that are made
in laboratories that have allowed them to
grow so big. Yeah, I mean I feel the same.
I'm going to sound so stupid to your male
audience because I don't know the ins
and outs of sports.
I'm not a big sports fan,
but that's kind of how I feel about
professional basketball games. Right?
So like I go and see Christian
play basketball and I
love it because they don't
take any breaks and I'm like awesome.
I get to watch them play
and I really get into it.
You Watch the NBA and there was like a
freaking timeout called every two minutes
and you're like, Jesus Christ,
just keep playing the game.
And I understand there are good reasons
for it. It's all part of the strategy.
But for someone like me
who's not a big sports fan,
I get turned off really quickly because
I'm like, oh great. Next commercial break.
All right,
we're going to wait.
Like it loses the momentum of
the game and I lose interest.
Well,
for sports fans,
I think what happens is you have these
highs and lows and you just sort of like
settle in through the lows while they're
blown whistles and moving guys over
here and talking about this
and arguing about that.
And it gives you things to debate.
Like that's a bullshit call.
There's fucking ref to retard and it gives
you shit to talk about when you're at
home. Like I like when a
on Twitter, after fights,
I don't even fucking read comments.
I'm like the last people I want to hear
about his people that didn't like the
way I call a fight on Saturday.
There's fucking queer and he's
fucking fake Jujitsu. Those,
it's just like opening up the devil's
asshole and looking for advice get and
this, but that's part of the fun part of
the fun of being a sports fan is getting
pissed off at shit and it's like,
it's an American outlet,
a uniquely American outlet.
Like American sports radio.
I've done a bunch of radio
shows with sports radio guys.
They're very unique and that they'll
just start shitting on these players.
Well let's, let's be honest, he's lazy.
The fucking guy never
gets up before practice.
He's not putting in the extra hours.
She doesn't want it and like, oh,
I got to agree with you. He's
got no heart. He's got no art.
He's a fucking super athlete in the NFL.
What the fuck are you talking about?
Yeah,
but that's the style of like shitting
on them and they get these free shots
because I mean this guy is a ray rice
or a super athlete type dude. I mean,
not ray rice, because his, his
thing wasn't about sport itself.
It was about violence. But like, you
know, pick one, you know,
pick any superstar who's a
superstar football player,
like awesome. Running back,
uh, currently demarco Murray,
demarco Murray. It's like that
guy that's, you know, come on.
Dealing with stud athletes.
Very rare people. Yeah.
I think the issue with the head traumas
60, he's gonna do it no matter what.
They're just going to do it
well, that's on them. Like I,
I believe in individual liberty.
If you want to do something
that's going to harm yourself,
then you should have the
freedom to do it right.
But I want to make sure that there's as
much information and education out there
as possible. So you make an educated
decision. That's true. Yeah.
I think that's true. Or that's
a, that's a very valid, and the,
the idea that they knew about the
damage beforehand, they withheld it.
That's not cool. That means you're working
with people who don't really like you.
Well, the NFL agreed to a settlement.
I don't remember the exact, uh,
number. It was 200 million, a little more
than $200 million. I remembered that.
But I don't remember the exact figure.
Anyway,
part of their settlement was that they
wouldn't have to release the studies or
the findings about the
concussions and the head trauma.
And I thought that that was so shady.
Now that was the original
settlement agreement and I
believe a judge struck that
down. So, um, we'll see what
the outcome of it is. But yes,
we reported on that over a year
ago and it was wrong. I mean,
when I read about that,
I was like,
how freaking shady are
you guys think about it?
They make so much money out
of these athletes. And true,
the athletes make millions of dollars
in a lot of cases as well. But I mean,
it's so disproportionate when you think
about the health consequences of what
they're playing. Um, I don't know.
I just, I worry about all that.
But there's a good, you're, you're making
a good argument. You know, it's also the,
the other point that you have that's
very good is that these guys are making
millions of dollars and they wouldn't
necessarily be making that kind of money
doing other things. No, and
they're uniquely built for sports.
I mean these people,
like if you were just around a guy who
was the size of an NFL lineman and he
just worked in your office,
she'd be like, Jesus,
the fuck you do like walk into
him in the kitchen, you know,
you're on your way to the coffee machine.
You're like,
what the fuck is this guy doing here?
There's huge people like Matt Mitre.
Aon is a fighter in the UFC. He was a,
he was a Lineman,
I believe he was a lineman in the NFL.
I know he played in the NFL. Look
that up. See if there's a alignment.
Every time I interview him he says,
fucking giant human.
Like if this guy was just hanging out at
a bar and he was angry, you would be, ah,
shit. The giants angry. You know,
you want that guy worn out from
football practice. Okay, fair.
Want him running up hills and
bash into other giant dudes.
Like if you don't have that outlet for
a dude, like that is terrifying. I mean,
I'm sure that there could be precautions
taken to lessen the number of people
who suffer from co concussions. I don't
know how, I don't know how interesting.
Because with a game like rugby,
the rate of concussions is actually much
lower than regular football players.
Right. And it's because they don't have
the same type of protection that football
players have. So there are a lot more
careful with what they do. Um, yeah.
Yeah. Um, that's actually an
issue with MMA as well. Uh,
I've been actually saying over the last
couple of months and I've had a bunch of
guys agree with me that are fighters,
that thing we shouldn't have
gloves and the gloves, uh,
what they're really doing is sometimes
they actually, there's a lot of,
I poke problems in the UFC and a lot of
these guys are saying that the gloves
actually are pulling your fingers apart.
So as your hands get
tired and you're fighting,
sometimes the gloves are
difficult to keep close.
It actually requires
resistance to close them.
So there's accidental I
pokes that are happening.
They think that with bare knuckles
also you'd be more judicious with your
punches because it's really
easy to break your hand.
Like especially if you hit someone in
the head like in their forehead with the
back of two knuckles,
these were really weak.
They're not really supportive that well
I can karate that kind of teach you to
use the front two muscles,
front two knuckles rather.
But if your bare handed you,
you have a really high
likelihood of hurting your
hands and you also your wrists,
I don't think you're rich should be
taped up cause people get to tape their
wrist,
they table up tight and that what your
risk doesn't move when you punch people
to Lazio Punch him way harder because
like you having your hands wrapped and
everything like that,
that's an unnatural state for your hands
and it turns them into weapons because
ordinarily they're kind of vulnerable
and if you break them, it's huge.
A guy breaks his hand in a fight,
has huge problems is now you can't
punch with this hand effectively.
You only have one hand. And if
you, even if you have to grapple,
like you probably are not going
to able to squeeze hard with it,
so you're fucked.
Oh,
what the hell it got you into UFC fighting
like just an excess of testosterone.
You want to beat the shit out of
people. Like, Ooh, no, no, no. Honestly,
I got into martial arts when I was a
kid because I was very insecure and very
lost and I needed
something to like put me,
put me in a challenging environment
where I could put like some physical
intensity into something that was very
competitive and very dangerous and scary
to me.
So it became what the way my instructor
used to describe it is that it's a
vehicle for her human potential
developing human potential.
And that when you're doing
with martial arts is not,
you're not trying to kick people's asses,
you kind of are,
but what you were really trying to do
is you're trying to do something that's
unbelievably difficult and scary.
And in doing so,
you develop your character in a very
profound way that a lot of people don't.
They don't experience the terror of
someone trying to kick your head off.
Like literally you feel the whoosh of
heels going by your head that would have
separated you from your
consciousness with with no doubt,
and you see it happening left and right
around you see guys getting acts kicked
in, the head, kicked in the head,
turning side kick to the body and they
crumble like they got hit by a car.
I've just seen that so many times.
It's how fine.
I can't imagine what the adrenaline
is like right before a fight.
It's very hard to manage.
Some people have the biggest issues with
managing the adrenaline and you see it
in the UFC all the time with guys
who were having their first fight.
We've caught octagon shock because it's
so intense like all these lights are on
and the camera's on. You like, Holy Shit,
I'm in the fucking UFC because they've
been fighting and all these smaller
organizations.
Right?
Very few people have seen it and they've
developed this record and they've got
some good skills and then all of a sudden
this just wave of adrenaline hits them
and they're like, Holy Shit. Their
heart's going like you could see it.
The breathing heavy.
They're trying to calm themselves down.
It's very hard to manage.
No,
I can't imagine it.
So one thing that I've always been really
terrified about is I'm skydiving and I
know, I know fuck all that. So Christian,
I have been talking about
doing it together. One
one one day, one the next day.
The other way, if one of you dies,
you can miss the other.
If you both die together,
it'd be so we'd feel like we're fucking,
it is.
I know, I know. I love
you. I love you too.
It's over.
I feel like I'd almost prefer that if I,
if I had an option between,
that's the romantic,
I guess you guys are really in love.
It's unbearable.
It's from Romeo and Juliet type shit.
One of the things.
One of the things that scares me about
skydiving isn't even the act of me like
already outside of the plane and
seeing the ground come toward me.
I'm more afraid of the
feeling that you get,
the adrenaline rush that you get
before you jump out of the plane.
I don't like a drone adrenaline. That's a
shitty feeling. Okay? I don't understand.
People that are adrenaline junkies,
you're talking to them just
picturing feet on the edges, looking
down, holding onto the side called,
fuck, fuck, fuck, fuck, fuck, fuck,
fuck, fuck, fuck, fuck. I just,
I can't, I mean, we're
going to end up doing it,
but I know I'm going to be miserable.
Who was it that was on the podcast?
Was it someone on the podcast?
It told the story about the first
time they went skydiving there.
First parachute didn't work. They
had to cut it off. Oh my God.
Was that someone in the podcast?
Was it someone someone was talking to me?
Might've been Steve Graham. God
didn't. No, it wasn't Steve.
I've got to remember who
the fuck told me this story.
But they went skydiving and they're
fucking parachute didn't work. They had,
the guy had him, he put, he goes,
we got an issue here. He goes,
what would that mean? He goes, well,
I'm going to have to cut this parachute
loose and we're going to go with the
backup. And like what? He's like,
what? So he's on the, you know,
this guy's on his back, you know,
this is how, you know, you know,
they do that like they're about to choke
you and that's how you fly through the
air.
I just wouldn't want to know.
And he's fucking song off the other
one so it doesn't get tangled up in the
second one when he pulls the backup. And
if that doesn't work, you're a Foxville.
No, no. We're not doing it. Doing,
I don't want to talk you out of it.
But my, uh, my friend Brian,
Brian Redman, you've met him.
His Dad was working with this person.
I forget it was a man or a woman.
Was it a woman? He's told the
store. I think it was a man. Um,
working might've been woman.
Anyway,
we're working with this person and
they were always trying to get them to
skydive. Like, come on, you've got to come
with us. It's awesome. It's such a rush.
Oh yeah. Yeah. Okay. Just so I
get to find the time, you know,
I'm with my kid on the weekends and then
one day he shows up at work at Monday
and he's like, where's this person?
They died skydiving. Oh my God. Really?
Oh Shit.
That's you hitting a lawn.
It's your body in the lawn
coming from 10,000 feet.
Just kidding towards earth
being sucked into the gravity.
I feel like when I feel like my
life's pretty exciting. Yeah.
I have an exciting life. I don't need to
jump out of a plane to feel like it's,
and by the way, as I was
looking up, um, you know,
skydiving tickets and
all that other stuff,
I did look up the number of people that
die per year due to skydiving accidents
just to, and it's actually not as
rare as I thought it would be. Okay.
Like I thought it would be like one person
has died over the last 10 years and I
know there, there are a lot of accidents
that happen. How many was it a year?
I don't remember. But it was enough.
Let's guess sky diving. It was like,
I think it was like 11 out of a
thousand or something like that. Maybe.
I don't remember the
number, but it was, it was,
that alone is enough to
make me uncommercial.
I don't know what that means though,
as far as,
I don't know how many
people are skydiving.
So if it's 1100 thousand how many yeah,
many people do you think die every year?
If you had to guess,
I'm going to go with like 25.
Hmm.
Okay. Hold on. Don't pull
it up yet cause I got a yes.
Yeah.
Hmm. Let's see. Um,
I'm going to guess 50 50. Wow. That's a
high number out of how many do you say?
I Dunno, per year. Oh, all right. I got
the number here. 42.5 fatalities per year.
42 fuck that.
It says the 1970s. Hold on. It says,
uh, in the 1980s, the average was 34.
Okay. What do you got? I
got a 21 out of 3 million.
Hmm. In 2010, 2013 is the last
year they have it and they have,
it's 24 24 all right.
As a 25 so that's still too much for me.
Yeah, it's out of 3.2 million jumpers.
But if you look at this calendar,
this is pretty crazy because if you
look at this, the schedule, what,
what's the data? What's really crazy
is they're showing you the numbers.
You get 2013 and then you get 24 and then
you get estimated animal annual jumps,
3.2 million. Okay. Fatalities
per jump, very low.
But when you look at it on paper,
imagine you were living
in one town where this many people
fell from the sky every year,
okay?
If all
skydiving was only in Kenosha, Wisconsin,
and you're working on a farm in Kenosha,
and you just,
every day you're here,
there's 32 and a fucking year,
that's more than one a month.
More than once a month.
Someone falls from the fucking sky and
die screaming as they slam into a planet.
2000 30202000130 five 35 bodies
in a year falling from the sky.
If it was in one neighborhood,
it would fucking sock.
It would literally be
raining people every day.
You would go outside terrified that
you're going to fucking get in your car.
Startup,
good doge and a guy comes from the sky
and slammed in the euro hoods, Joe,
but you've already convinced
me to not go sky diving.
You don't need to do any more.
I'm not trying to convince you,
I'm not trying to convince you, but I'm
just imagining that I'm living in a town.
You know, just let's say Chicago. It's
a city. It's a host city. Big City.
35 people fall from the fucking sky
on a Chicago a year. You'd be like,
what the fuck are you guys
doing? And look, the craziest
part about it is it wasn't
something necessary, right?
It was something that you
paid for and it's expensive.
It's like hundreds of
dollars to go skydiving.
So you just paid hundreds
of thousands of dollars,
hundreds of thousands or
hundreds of dollars to die.
Yeah. Well, yeah. Essentially with
someone attached to your back,
but it's gotta be a rush. Otherwise
they wouldn't be doing it. Yeah.
I don't need that rush.
You know that that story was from Ryan
Parsons and they had video. That's right.
That's right. It was Ryan video
of it. Oh God, that's right.
No, we're not watching that.
No, no, no, no, no, no, no. I
don't mean to watch that. Yeah.
I don't even like hiking next to
a cliff because I'm like worried.
I might like step the wrong way and
somehow roll down the cliff and die.
You have to worry about shit dropping on
you too. Yeah. This room's things fall.
You know,
you always drive by when you're driving
down roads and there's lows falling rock
signs, you see rocks on the road. Yeah.
Like if you're below one of those rocks,
they hit you in the fucking head and your
dad's Ville or your windshield. Yeah.
It's scary.
Okay.
There.
But this is a certain amount of fun
in being in those weird environments
that are kind of dangerous,
like as long as you recognize it. It's
where like hiking, it's when you do the,
you're careful and you
know what you're doing.
There's like a certain weird thrill to it.
When I was in Alaska,
we were this island called
Prince of Wales and uh,
there was a deer that was below us and
we were like sitting on the edge of this
rock and it was literally a fucking cliff.
So there's the edge of this cliff
and I'm looked down, I'm like, yeah,
whole fucker.
My whole body like Titan.
He's like, you don't want to go
near that cliff, do you? I go, no,
I don't want to go.
I don't want to go near that cliff.
Like I'm not going to sit like she's
sitting there with his legs dangled over
the edge. I'm like, that shit.
Fuck that shit for.
Not any like,
dad's not interested in sitting with his
legs dangling over a cliff and there's
like a fucking thousand
foot drop underneath them
or whatever the hell it is.
500 foot drop at least
you're dead or you're like,
no, no interest in that.
No interest in that.
That fucking thing that it does to
your body when you see someone do that,
when you look, look over a ledge and
you see that view and you're like,
oh the dude, some people get
off on that, like not sexually,
but like they get a rush that
they're addicted to and I don't,
I don't know what it is about people
who, who love that, but I don't,
I really don't. Maybe I'm a boring person,
but I like being comfortable. Well,
it's a, it's a weird thing to love,
to love, to be scared. You know,
you don't want to die. You don't want
to get hurt, but you want to be scared.
It's a weird thing, but it's really
common. I mean, look at roller coasters.
The scariest fuck most fucked up things
you could do in your life these days or
go to some of those like magic mountain
rollercoasters yeah. Holy Shit.
Those are terrifying. Yeah, it was at
one, they have the x something or another.
They have a one called the viper
and one called the x. The X one.
You can't even have
anything in your pockets.
They strap you to this concoction spins
you around all this fucking chaos.
And it is so terrifying because
you're like, if this thing goes wrong,
MYP shit, it's just breaking apart.
You're just going to put bodies,
you can get ripped to shreds.
You're going to get smashed into the
gears of this machine is so powerful that
it's whipping 200 people
simultaneously around, you know,
surprisingly roller coasters
don't scare me at all.
Not even a little bit like I don't
mind roller coasters. I just,
anything where I am, there's like a
free fall involved, I'll get scared. Um,
but other than that, I feel like I can
handle it. Roller coasters are great.
I love roller coasters,
but there's always that somewhere in your
mind has to recognize that people have
died on his fucking pants. It's not
very many. It's very few. Yep. Very,
very few. Most likely you're going to be
fine, but you might not be. I mean, look,
you put your life in danger every time
you get behind the wheel and you drive.
I'm averaging an accident a year at
this point. Is this that thing, Jamie,
what is it called? Magic
Mountain. Oh, good Lord. Justin,
when I did this fucking thing.
Oh God.
They give you all a locker.
Okay. This ride so fucked up.
You get all locker.
You get to put your shit in a locker so
you don't have anything in your pockets
because anything that's in there, it's
just going to fly into someone's eyeball.
The top thrilled dragster at Cedar Point
I've been on you go to 120 miles an
hour, I think in like three seconds
and up to 420 feet within six.
Fuck the fuck are you saying? And then
straight down kind of look at this.
It's a roller coaster where you're
hanging upside down and spinning around in
circles.
Oh good Lord.
You're just experiencing it from
watching it from an outside perspective.
If you're sitting in those seats,
it's madness.
You're fucking up feel when it was over,
like usually when the
rollercoaster is done, I'm like,
my entire body's kind of trembling,
but when you're in the moment
you don't feel it like it.
And I don't mind that feeling.
The thing that I don't like is just the
anticipation of something that scares
me. So like again,
jumping out of that plane,
like the moment before I jump out of the
plane is what scares me the most. Um,
but yeah, when I'm in the middle of
it, I feel like I can handle it fine.
I think a lot of fighters
get addicted to that,
overcoming that moment and being calm
and peaceful in that moment, you know?
Because especially like what I did doing
taekwondo is not nearly as terrifying
is doing MMA because MMA is just,
it's just a,
it's more likely that someone's going
to have an answer to your bullshit.
And then it is if you're
just doing one discipline,
whether it's boxing or something
like that, just so many variables,
it's really easy to get smashed and it's,
it's hard to beat everybody in MMA.
It's one of the more difficult sports
to become like truly dominant in. Yep.
And so when these guys are
getting into that cage,
like you could see this wrestling match
with this anticipation with all this
nervous energy and it's a huge part
of it for them because when they win,
you never seen anybody
happier. Yeah. When,
when a guy has like a huge victory the
UFC and they throw their arms up and they
fuck like there's this, there's
craziness to it. It's just,
you don't, you can't imagine someone
being like more excited to win something,
you know, like you don't ever like
win a game of ping pong and go like,
they jump up there,
they're just so pumped up that
they literally can't control it.
That's how I feel at the end of the day
when I haven't read a comment asking me
to sit on someone's face like,
fuck no, I get that kind of,
I get that kind of Shit on daily basis.
So if I go like one day without reading
like a crazy ass comment, I'm like,
oh by God it's okay.
Good day.
Problem is they probably
get you condition.
So if you want a few months without any
of those comments, he'd be like, Hey,
come on.
Well, every now and it was finished
it on their face. What the fuck?
Come on every now and again to my boys,
I'm not saying cut it out entirely.
How rude. Imagine if that was okay.
Okay. So you just, you know,
once you missed it you like shit.
No, but you know, the one
thing that I did realize is,
I mean in the very beginning of
my career, I guess, um, when I,
when people wouldn't focus on what I was
talking about and then all the comments
were about what I look
like, I was like, Ugh, God,
no one's paying attention
to what I'm saying. Then.
And I was like kind of heard about it
and then I realize like these people are
telling me I'm attractive.
There are worse things in the world.
Yeah. With my life. You got a super
lucky roll. The dice. Yeah. Medically.
Thank you. That's very sweet. Yeah. Right.
So like if they're saying that you're hot,
that's fine. Let it, yeah. Yeah. I don't,
so I don't mind those comments anymore.
But it is,
it's a weird thing that men
do to dismiss women, right?
They'll talk about your looks or your
makeup or something like your heels,
you know, that's, that's cheap.
That's like a cheap tactic.
Like if someone's talking about an,
and you start talking shit about
their makeup, you know, like, oh,
like girls in heels and look at her with
a little skirt. Yeah. But then again,
for the male's point of view, it's
very weird that you get to wear skirts.
Really. Do you want to wear a
skirt? I mean, I wouldn't judge. You
don't want to wear a skirt.
However,
it's very weird that one gender gets to
regularly expose their shaved legs and
flip them back and forth and
interviews. And it's very strange. Yeah,
it's very odd that you have the
one gender that is more desirable,
physically more pursued.
If you had a bet like who's pursuing more
as women or women pursuing men more or
men pursuing women war for sure.
Men are pursuing women more so the,
the women are more pursued
but more exposed in their
attire on a regular basis.
Like just a tiny piece of cloth separating
your vagina from the cold hard world.
And that's standard business clothes.
Yeah, that's kind of odd, right?
I guess. But you know, it's
funny because there's, there are,
there are different schools of feminism,
right? I just said feminism, Europe,
viewers just like lost interest
and started throwing up anyway.
Just stay with me. Stay
with me, please. Okay.
So there's one school that
thinks like if you are a woman,
do not flaunt your sexuality. Do
not embrace femininity, rejected.
Um, because that if you do
flaunt it, that's all people
are going to focus on. And,
but like, I fucking hate that
school of thought, right?
Because I think femininity is great.
And I like embracing the differences
between men and women. Men,
women are not equal.
That doesn't mean that men are better
than women or that women are better than
men. We're freaking
different. Right? Yeah.
And so embrace the fact that you have
differences, but expect or, or yeah,
expect equality when it
comes to situations regarding
employment and things like
that. Right. But yeah, I mean,
I'd love to do like, you know,
sociological, historical, um,
research to figure out why it is that
women can dress that way and men don't,
whatever it is. But also, I dunno,
it's funny because going back to what
you said about men pursuing women more,
I think that that is changing
slowly based on with Tinder.
Sure.
Okay.
So there's that element of his are
out there just banging left and right.
These crazy kids,
there's that element of it.
But I also think that as women become
more dominant in the workforce,
I think you're seeing more and more women
feel confident enough to pursue men.
At least that's my experience.
I
think it's insulting to think that a
woman can't wear whatever the fuck she
wants. Whatever she likes to wear,
the way they dress, the way she wants,
and still be intelligent. Yeah, that's,
that's really like a form of sexism
inside of like your own gender.
It's like you're, you're separating
the idea of like a serious woman. Yup.
You know, a serious woman and
a woman who wants to look sexy.
Well says who says you?
Yeah. So it's who, who's the,
who's the one who gets to
make this call and you know,
here's where it gets really weird.
The one exception to that as far as like
women dressing up and like really like
skimpy outfits and looking really sexy
and wearing high heels and makeup and
really girling up.
The one exception is transgender women.
Transgender women are always supported
as deep as they go into the woman
category. Like as deep as they go
into the femininity care. You go girl,
you go girl. Yeah. Nobody ever says
to like a transgender woman, hey,
you're dressing like a whore. You
know, they give her some slack.
I think that the same courtesy
should be extended to anyone and,
and whatever a woman wants to where I
am supportive of it just because like
someone might wear something that
I wouldn't want to wear myself,
but that doesn't mean that I should sit
around and like judge them and say, Oh,
I'm not going to take
this person seriously.
So I got to give a quick example
because this kind of shows you how
progressive's can go too far
when it comes to certain things.
So I have this friend from Grad School,
um,
who is like a hardcore progressive,
right.
And he was co I commented on or I did
a status update on Facebook when I
recently went to France
for a media conference.
I didn't know that I had to walk around
on the plane or else my legs would get
fucking swollen as I've ever seen them.
Like they got really swollen,
so none of my shoes fit
once I finally landed. Um,
and so I wrote on Facebook that I had
to buy a new pair of shoes that were a
size and a half larger than
what my feet really are,
just so I can wear heels
to this conference. And he
commented back and he's like,
why are you wearing heels and why are you
subscribing to the male expectation of
femininity and beauty and you're doing a
disservice to feminism? And I was like,
really? I was like, you're in towards,
you find it ironic that you as a dude are
now telling me what I should wear as a
woman in order to follow the right
perspective of femininity or feminism,
I should say. So that really made
me, made me upset because for me,
wearing high heels isn't
about attracting men. Sure.
There's some part of it in there.
But what I actually love about wearing
heels is it makes me stand straight.
It makes me feel sexy.
It makes me feel confident.
And I feel like once I put it on a
pair of heels, I can rule the world.
It has very little to do
about attracting males.
Yeah. You should be able to
wear whatever the fuck you want.
If Gene Simmons could wear those boots
with the teeth on the bottom of them and
still be one of the manliest
man ever. I mean, come on.
He said we were boots that went all the
way up to his knees. Nobody complained.
Nobody give us back your man card with
your feminine outwit, but the shoes, boy,
what's up with the fucking
shoes? Disappoint me. No,
you know he doesn't have to go on stage
at timberlands on some fucking Rodeo
belt. Buckle shoes. He's
wearing leather pants.
Come on. He's got fucking glitter
all over his body. It's Marin makeup.
He's got makeup on. Yeah.
What the fuck where? Whatever
you want. Who gives a shit?
That's the problem is people were
getting genuinely upset about something.
That's none of their fucking business.
Absolutely,
and they're just deciding that because
they've met women who have dressed sexy.
All women would dress sexy, are
idiots, and they do with men.
The men who work out in many
workout of fucking Meta. Oh,
what are you going to the gym,
meathead.
They'll delve diminish you because you
work out. It's the same thing, you know.
Go Steve. Nice tight shirt. Yeah
it is. A lot of it comes through.
Looks good to be honest with you. Of
course it is, right? Yeah, of course.
I mean if you're a hot dude who's been
working out and you're getting criticism
from other guys because you're a meathead,
you're coming from a jealous place.
I liked it.
They've invented that dude bro thing.
Cause it really is very
quickly diminishing. Yeah.
Like if someone says anything,
yeah, he's the most dude bro Guy
ever. Ooh. Wow. That fucking hurts.
Actually it works. Cause he ever knows
what they're talking about. You know,
like a dude bro.
It's just like a blur.
It's such a great thing to say because
he can't even get upset at someone saying
it. Cause it's not even like
you're a cunt face. You know?
It's like he's a dude bro.
Like I don't even know what you said.
They don't know what that
means. So diminishing, but
it's so effective. Yeah. Yeah.
Well, you know, people
are weird. They're weird.
We're weird at what we get upset
about, you know, me included,
I get upset about shit and then I go,
why do I care what the fuck is wrong with?
Okay, yeah, that happens time to time.
I will definitely feel that
especially doing what I do.
Like sometimes I'll get upset
about a story and I'm like, wait,
why am I letting this get
to me? Yeah. You know,
and then sometimes we'll do a story where
it'll have this profound effect on me
recently.
Um,
I don't know if you read about George
Stinney who was executed in 1944.
This 14 year old boy,
I heard that he was exonerated recently.
He was exonerated recently
executed in 1944, um,
because he was convicted of
killing two white girls. Uh,
so he had nothing to do with it, as
you guys know, exonerated recently.
And um,
we were doing the show and our
COO Steevo came in and he's like,
hey guys,
I'm sorry to interrupt the show,
but I want to give you a quick update
on a story that I find important.
And then he gave us the details.
I had never heard about George
Stinney until that moment.
And I don't know what it was.
But when he told me about that 14
year old who weighed 90 pounds getting
executed for a crime, he didn't
commit. I couldn't hold back tears.
And for the first time in a really,
really long time,
I was about to burst into tears on
camera and we had to go to break.
So I can kind of like,
you know, contain myself.
Do you not want people
to see you grow? Um, I,
so I want to be as a woman,
it's difficult because you don't
want people to immediately go to, oh,
she's just an emotional female. She's
not a reliable source of news. Right.
A lot of people think that if
you're passionate about something,
that means that you're irrational and
that you're just an emotional girl.
And so I go out of my
way regardless of how,
how much I want to like break down.
I go out of my way to make sure
I don't cry on camera. Cause.
And then also whenever you cry on camera,
I immediately think of like the Glen
Becks of the world who were like super
fucking cheesy and they like,
they're doing it,
they're doing it to ham up the audience.
Right.
Yeah.
I don't think you should ever worry about
being fake because you don't give off
any of that. So I think if you felt
like crying on camera, cry on camera,
but if you don't feel like crying on
camera, you don't have to do that either.
Yeah. That's, it's interesting
to wonder why. Like I've never cried
on camera either, but I've cried.
I've cried it on movies
and shit. Yeah. I cry.
I have daughters are crazy.
I'm a bit
aw,
I do, I cry. I cry for no
fucking reason. Uh, it's,
it's pretty easy to like a good song
or a good like, you know, especially
anything where anything where,
you know,
people are losing loved ones. So, yeah.
I remember I watched this documentary
once. It was like a one of these,
I'm not a documentary, like a, um,
it was a cable show that was documenting
Malibu fires and these fires where it's
just devastating fires that
swept through this hillside,
destroyed all these homes.
And this one guy who was a fireman and a,
he had a house that he worked his
whole life to build. And um, he,
he built it himself and you know,
it didn't make a lot of money,
but he saved up enough to buy this piece
of land and literally build his own
house over the course of
several years by himself.
And he was living in it and his house
was spared, but his neighbors wasn't.
And this guy was just weeping,
just weeping,
weeping for his
neighborhood, for, you know,
the idea of losing his own house
and this whole thing. And, uh,
I was watching this in the green room
of a show that I was about to do. Oh.
And then I had to go on stage is where
before I realized you can't do that.
Like I'd only been doing comedy a few
years. I Wa I was a rookie. And so, uh,
I was doing this show with this guy,
JB Smoove.
I don't know if you know who he is. He
was on a curb. Your enthusiasm. Hilarious.
Hilarious comedian. And it was supposed
to be, JB was supposed to go up first,
but then I was supposed to go up second.
But JB got lost.
It was a college in New Jersey and
he was in the middle of nowhere.
It was really hard to find. I got
there early, but I was, I went, I got,
I left way early and just got there early.
So they told me to just sit in the
green room and watch some TV and relax.
No worries.
We'll start the show whenever.
And so I'm sitting there watching these
people cry in this girl calling for her
dog. She's calling for a dog,
you know, she's like rusty,
rusty. That fucking dog is
dead. You know, it's dead.
And you got a camera on this girl while
she's calling for this nonexistent doc.
It's a God damn inferno.
It looks like Satan came over the
mountain with fucking flaming horses.
It looks horrible and they're focusing
on this girl. There's sucking you in,
showing you the humanity of the situation.
Oh my God. Crying like a bitch and then I
got to go on stage. No, that's tough man.
That's tough. It's hard to, you know,
gather your thoughts after you see
something traumatic like that and it,
it really like hits you the first time.
I've only cried on camera twice. Okay.
So I just mentioned the George Stinney
story. That was the recent incident. Um,
the first time I ever cried on camera
was actually years ago and we did a story
about, I think it was a natural
disaster that happens somewhere,
I don't remember. But um, someone
had died and as a result of the natural
disaster and he got buried and there was
this photo of his dog just
sitting and waiting by his grave.
And I don't know,
like I just like understanding the
loyalty of that dog and he's there.
He showed that someone didn't tell him
to lie down, right? No, no. It was, no,
it was a real story.
I don't know if the dog had like maybe
the family members went to the burial or
whatever and the dog route, like
realized that I have no idea. But it was,
and it was, it was reported by a
very credible news organizations.
So it wasn't like, oh look, this was
posted on reddit and it's real. No,
it was like,
yeah,
well it was like the Associated Press
or Reuters or something like that. Um,
the problem with those stories as they
sound great and so there's no harm in
them being bullshit.
Yeah.
You can just put it out there was a dog
and a fucking come around you out. No,
the dog's going to be like, Yo, this
is bullshit. Do they gave me a bone.
They told me the light on there.
I don't know where that dude's bird
fuck this bullshit stories bullshit.
So it's a no risk so they can just
make shit up. Well that's true. Yes.
And you're right. That's like a
harmless made up story if it is made up.
But the worst thing is when you have like
credible news organizations or like a
magazine like rolling
stone doing a really,
really terrible job with that Uva
story. Do you know about that? Yes.
That's unfortunate.
It's unfortunate
because you know,
it's very unfortunate when you
release a story that has troubles, um,
and that these troubles could
have been investigated before,
especially when it's on a very,
very,
very sensitive topic that everyone
knows needs to be addressed. Everyone,
I don't think there's a single person
that doesn't believe it's sexual assault
isn't a problem. It's a huge
problem. You haven't been online.
No. Everybody must know. Everybody
must know that it's possible.
Everybody must know that women
can get sexually assaulted,
right? So whenever you,
you know that that is true, it has
happened. It's 100%. It's undeniable.
If you have a situation where
someone is accusing someone of,
covering something up along,
it's like you've got to go over
that bitch with a fine tooth comb.
You can't leave them with any evidence
that points because it not only is if,
if you, if you fail to make a credible
story that can't be backed up,
not only does it fail in that attempt,
but it strengthened the resolve of the
other people that think there's a lot of
false rape accusers,
100%
I that story did so much damage
to those who actually are,
and who knows? This Jackie girl
might actually be a rape victim,
but maybe she can't recall the
specific events. I don't know.
I don't know what her story is.
I have no evidence.
I don't even want to comment
on that. Right? But regardless,
the misreporting and the misinformation
that was portrayed in that rolling stone
piece does a disservice to the actual
rape victims out there who are trying to
get people to believe them.
But people are denying that they went
through something as terrible as rape. And
it's funny, I teach a journalism
course at cal state Northridge, right?
And Journalism Ethics One oh one is
that you get both sides of the story.
That doesn't mean that you are neutral.
You should be objective. Right?
But don't be like, oh,
this side says this,
that side says that now you guys
decide I'm against that. Right.
But you still have to get both sides
of the story and then you as an
investigative journalists need to
go out there and seek the truth.
And that didn't happen with
the rolling stone piece.
They agreed with Jackie that they would
not corroborate her account of the
events with anyone else. What kind of
fucking journalism is that? That's crazy.
I mean that story actually really pissed
me off because that did a lot of harm.
How do you think that that kind of an
agreement gets put into place where
someone says, we won't
corroborate the facts of the case?
Like we won't try to
investigate it any further.
Like why would someone agree to that?
It doesn't really make sense. Right?
I think maybe I'm going to give
them the benefit of the doubt,
but maybe they understood that this is a
sensitive story and here is a woman who
is a potential rape victim and they
want to be very sensitive to her.
And so they kind of like
walk on egg shells for her.
But so that's like the best case scenario
for rolling stone if that's what their
intentions were.
The worst case scenario is if,
and I don't know if this is the case,
but if you have a journalist who has her
own biases and she uses those biases to
justify only using one
source for her story,
I don't know which one of
those two scenarios actually
occurred, but nonetheless,
the outcome was disastrous and it was,
I mean that story came out,
um,
or the aftermath of that story came
out when my class was winding down.
But if I get the honor of
teaching that class again,
I'm going to bring up that case and
I'm going to be like, do not do this.
This is the most irresponsible
type of journalism you can do.
It's super unfortunate too
because it can be avoided. Yeah,
it can be avoided with due diligence.
And that's the one thing that people
complain the most about like web sites.
Like they don't really,
they're not really under any supervision.
Like they could do whatever they want.
And you have excellent ones
and you have piss poor ones.
You have ones that report things
that are just totally made up.
I can't tell you how many,
how many times a week someone
sends you something that's,
it's not even a parody site, it's just
a complete made up site. They were,
there was a site where someone was sending
me new species of Hominid found and
they thought that they found
dead leprechauns these,
this a dude like he's, he's,
he's sweeping.
He's usually like a paintbrush to sweep
the side of a mountain and there's a
little dead leprechaun skeleton. Like, get
the fuck out of here, dude. It's really,
send me this. You asshole. But that's,
you know, that's the internet, you know,
and that's beautiful.
You can do whatever you want,
but you don't expect that
from like rolling stone from
rolling stone. I expect,
you know, it's God damn. That's where
hunters Thompson used to, right.
You're supposed to have like the
highest journalistic ethics ever.
You talk about important stories. You
have Matt motherfucking [inaudible] the,
I was about to mention,
I mean, Matt Taibbi is
amazing. He's a monster. He's
a freaking muck. Yeah, he is.
He's the most ever at that.
He's the best ever it down.
And he's brilliant to read too. It's, it's
fun stuff. Like he's, you know, he's a,
he's a, he's a fucking, he's a
journalistic gangsters. What it really is,
it really is. I mean, there are very few
journalists out there that I look up to.
Matt Taibbi is certainly one
of them. And so, so yeah,
I mean I think that that rolling stone
piece regarding Uva not only did damage
to people that have been raped, but it
also did damage to their own magazine.
It did damage to the other reporters
out there who do the due diligence
necessary to put out a responsible
news report. I don't know.
It was disheartening.
I did not like that at all.
I think people get super scared and
sensitive when it's dealing with that
subject. The subject of rape. It's
such a, you know, a dark subject.
So when people are dealing
with that, I think, you know,
sometimes they, they just,
they don't look at things as objectively
as they could if they weren't like
really locked into this like very kid
gloves approach to this one subject mean
all subjects were a victim or awful.
Whether it's molestation,
whether it's violence,
whether it's any, you know,
anything that happens like person
to person, human interactions,
it gets fucking sensitive is shit
including sexual stuff like rape.
It's all like super sensitive.
But when you're talking about
like a crime in a story,
there's this real fear of blaming the
victim or this real fear of questioning
the victim and the real fear of stepping.
I mean,
can imagine the horror of being raped
and then the horror of someone accusing
you of lying about that rate when
it actually has happened. So that's,
it's very weighted because of
that. Rightly so. You know,
so everybody that approaches the
subject of rape is like very,
very kind and sensitive about it.
But it seems like in this case it's just
a fuck up because you're talking about
stuff that wouldn't be that hard to
look up. Like you could, you could just,
you know, and you don't even have
to like do it with that person.
You just start doing some
work and find out, you know,
who was in what fraternity and what,
what's social affairs were.
I mean they have to like keep logs of
shit and Jackie described someone that she
knew from years prior that
doesn't even go to the school.
I mean just simple little details from
her story. You can corroborate without,
let's say you don't want to talk to
anyone who was one of the alleged rapist,
right? Cause she was
allegedly gang raped. Right.
Let's say you want to just check
on the little facts like, okay,
was there a party thrown by the fraternity
on the date that Jackie specified?
That's a very simple thing to check out.
They didn't do that
irresponsible to save the least.
It's just crazy that it's rolling stone.
That's what's crazy.
It's just so it seems that, um,
it's also, everybody's like,
there's so much content out there. I
mean, there's so many different websites.
There's so much competition. There's
some, I mean, I think people were many,
maybe many times in a rush to get
salacious stories out because you know,
anything that's very
prominent and terrifying, like,
like, uh, a gang rape, you know,
people who have daughters think about,
oh my God, [inaudible] gang rape,
what he did,
why he got away with it.
And then there's also the issue of people
that experienced trauma that they lose
a lot of memory. That's a fact. People,
people who've had traumatic experiences,
the, the very impactful
emotions and fear and, and,
and self loathing and all the shit
that comes, a traumatic experiences.
A lot of times people black things out.
Like there's a lot of people who have
PTSD for events that have happened in
their life and they, you know,
really violent events, especially,
they just block them out. Like, you know,
I've talked to people that don't remember,
like big chunks of their life. Yeah.
And it's people who've
experienced some fucked up shit.
Exactly. Which is why it could have
happened. What could easily happen,
what Jackie mentioned or told a rolling
stone could have happened, but again,
it's up to rolling stone to do its due
diligence and make sure that everything
that she is reporting to them.
Yeah,
it's true. Yeah. There's sauce.
There's real issue of people just
not being truthful and being crazy.
You know, people like to
make things up. There are,
there are a certain amount of
people that for whatever reason,
they just will start talking and the
words will come out and they're just
talking about shit that actually never
really happened and they're just making
things up and I've met a bunch of
them. I'm sure you have to. Of course,
it's possible you can do it. You can like
lie and get pretty fucking far in life.
You can totally sneak through certain
gates and climb over certain walls.
Make it til you make it.
Yeah.
There's a lot of people to
get away with doing that.
So you'd never know when someone's telling
a story about anything where it's a,
he said, she said story, you really
never know until you look deeply into it.
What's going on.
Whatever small percentage of
false rape claims there are.
I don't know what the percentage is.
Like someone said it's like 2% or
something of all uh, rapes, uh, that are,
that people like claim
are false rape claim.
So it's just someone trying to get back
into ex boyfriend or someone trying to
fuck somebody over.
But that's still two out of a hundred.
You got to look at those.
Yeah. You got to you
those numbers aren't reliable.
You know,
it's really difficult to study something
like that. Um, but yeah, I mean
that's not victim blaming either. Okay.
That's just being rational and logical.
Yeah.
It's all that is.
And that there's this idea that you
shouldn't look at things rationally or
logical or you could, you shouldn't want
facts while still being kind, you know,
you can still be kind while you want
facts, you know. Look, it's unfortunate.
It's very unfortunate when you run into
someone who has made up stories cause
you're like, Oh you poor bastard,
you just as crazy liar person.
Yeah.
You know what's also really crazy is a
over the last two years there there've
been a number of stories of like teenage
girls who have been raped, right.
Drugged and raped at these parties.
Right.
And then they're rapists will take
pictures of them as they're passed out.
Naked Neuron. This is, this is
amazing. There was a girl named Jadah,
this happened to her and we
reported on her recently.
So rapist took pictures of her as she
was passed out and she had her leg bent
and like a peculiar position.
And then they started like basically
circulating that photo among their peers.
So all of a sudden a bunch of people
started bullying her for getting raped.
And so they started like a hashtag called
Jadah pose and they started posing in
pictures in the way that she was in
that photo. And just making fun of it,
like put, posting it on Twitter and
Facebook and bullying the crap out of her.
This happened in Houston and she,
what's amazing about this girl,
she was 16 when it happened.
She was resilient enough
to not let it destroy her.
And so the mainstream press has a policy
and I think it's a pretty good policy
of,
um,
hiding the name or the true identity of
a minor who's been sexually assaulted or
raped or anything like that. And
she came out and she's like, no,
I don't want anyone to hide my, my image.
I don't want anyone to hide my name.
I want to come out and
speak out against it.
Because a lot of teenagers go through
the same thing that I've been going
through and they, they
commit suicide. Right?
And so I think it's important to have a
really serious discussion about why kids
think that that kind of behavior is okay.
Because look in the school
district that I went to la USD,
we had comprehensive sex ED,
right? And in comprehensive sex Ed,
they talked about everything including
rape and sexual assault and molestation.
And those were really uncomfortable
conversations to have in middle school and
high school.
But I felt like my peers
had an understanding of
how serious situations like
that are and how you don't bully
someone who's a rape victim.
And since this happened in Houston,
I'm wondering whether or not they had the
exposure to the same type of education
that we had.
Right.
Because if you understand the
weight of sexual assault and rape,
you wouldn't make fun of
or bullied the victim.
You see what I'm saying? So
I don't know. I don't know.
That's just my speculation and
it's like a hypothesis that I have,
but I'm really curious to look into it
cause how vicious is that to make fun of
someone who's been raped,
children lack perspective, they don't
have a lot of experience in life.
And there's a lot of
what being a child is,
which is essentially a reflection of the
people that are around you when you're
growing up and they're very
young, they're, you know,
you're talking about kids that
are less than 18 years old, right?
They all have pathways that have been
beaten into their brain by either family
or circumstance or being around
the knuckleheads they're around.
And a lot of times they lack
perspective and people are also,
they're also terrified and
confused and everyone is,
I mean every fucking young kid that grows
up that is a bully is probably just as
scared if not more scared than
the people that are bullying.
They're all terrified. Of course
you're doing a bunch of stupid shit.
You know that's like a big part
of being a young person in the,
the what the real issue is is we shouldn't
have young kids alone that much with
each other cause they get
all lord of the flies. Okay.
They're supposed to young
should have parental
supervision and then when
they get into their teenagers,
he should still have a lot of
real grown ass men around. Yeah.
Go Hey fucker. Like settle down.
Like stop every, what is it?
What are you guys doing?
Like yeah.
Let me explain to you what's wrong about
your behavior from someone who they
trust. Like a real woman who is
running the class is going to go,
everybody sit the fuck down.
Like what are you thinking you're going
to accomplish with this? What do you,
what exactly do you think you're gonna
accomplish by running through my fucking
classroom? Throwing pencils at
each other and pulling hair.
You guys are fucking
crazy. Sit down. Yeah,
and someone who talks to
them like that where they go,
oh well I respect Mrs. Johnson. She's
told us shut the fuck up and sit down.
But a teacher can't even say that.
It can even speak in the language that
the kids use on a regular basis on their
own because that's profane and sometimes
it's the only way you can get their
attention.
Dude.
That's why I love teaching at a university
level because at least you're able to
have that type of freedom,
right?
Like no one's sitting there telling
you what type of language you can use
or what new swearing your class.
I swear my class all the time.
Your class is fin to get packed right
now? No, I love my class sign up.
Is it like when I have to,
do I have to take some tests and shit?
How do I get in this?
No test? I mean, it's
a broadcast news class.
So I teach them how to put
news packages together.
We do mock production meetings that are
very similar to what you would have in
like a real newsroom. It's a fun class.
I love it. It's very interactive. Um,
but I tell them in the beginning like,
look, I'm not much older than you guys.
I'm 28, um, I cause I'm going to
talk to you as if I'm your peer,
but I'm not an easy professor. So
don't take advantage of that. Like,
I want to have a discussion.
I want us to like understand each other.
Like I have that whole spiel in the very
beginning and I want them to open up,
you know,
I want them to trust me and I want
them to respect me and have like a real
conversation with me when I'm
actually doing my lectures.
Because there's nothing worse than having
some monotone old fuddy duddy come in
and tell you like, okay, today we're
going to talk about journalistic ethics.
They're not going to pay attention
to that. I've had those professors.
Yeah.
So we use the word fuddy duddy
just knowing what a fuddy duddy is.
Yeah,
I mean people definitely would rather
communicate with somebody who they feel
like it's a regular person and you know,
university level.
Of course you could do that,
but with kids like my God,
you know like leaving them
alone to be mean to each other.
These 13 to 14 year olds like Hobo,
everybody fucking settled down like,
what do you guys, you don't even
know what you're doing here.
Are you being mean to this little girl?
Because somebody drugged her and fucked
her. Do you know how crazy that is?
Like you girls out of your mind like
ticket and also kids get ramped up and
rivalries to the point where
they want each other dead kid.
Like 14 year old kids
will fight to the death.
Like they literally
have this fucking bitch,
I want her dead and they fucking get out
of school and hit each other with their
purses and pull hair and dudes will like,
teenage boys are some of the most
dangerous people you ever run into because
they're physically, they start, they're
starting to get their testosterone,
they're starting to get strong.
They and they've only been doing,
they've only been strong for
a very short amount of time.
Like an 18 year old boy is essentially
only been man strong for like two years.
So he has this new thing over the lip,
sweet 16 and 18 I'm might be able
to fuck this dude up, you know,
and they have this weird thing about
them that they have to manage and if they
do that without any guidance,
if they do that with any supervision of,
they definitely do that without any tests,
trials and tribulations.
If they just don't ever get to express
that violent chimpanzee eco that's
ringing around inside our Adams, if
they don't express that, they'll,
they won't be able to control it. It,
it'll spin out into the trees. They don't,
they won't know what the
fuck they're doing. I mean,
this is part of the reason why growing up,
my mom never let me go to sleep
overs or camp or anything like that.
I'm sure like that engage shit.
Probably the prevalence of sexual assault.
What do you mean gay shit?
Girls get together camps.
Oh yeah.
I waited until I was like in my twenties
to get into that kind of stuff. Wow. Bao.
Um,
but yeah,
like I think my mom understood the kind
of things that happened when a bunch of
teenagers get together and
so she was like, nope, you're
not going anywhere. Yeah.
When I was, I went to boy scout camp
and they fucking tied this kid up,
but toothpaste all over his clothes,
they cheat. They took him, they,
they tied him to his,
uh,
his cot and they carry the cut into the
woods and we were in New Hampshire and
it was in the middle of fucking nowhere.
There was no light outside.
Like I'd never been to a place where it
was dark out because there was no moon
that night. You couldn't fucking
see your hand. Oh my God.
You're trying to see your hand.
You can't see your fucking hand.
Like there was no light. None.
And they put this to the fucking,
they brought them out into
the woods and left him there.
This guy is screaming soon.
Funny guys, this isn't funny.
And uh, they woke me up to one of
them grabbed me and I jumped up like,
fuck you dude.
You're not taking me out there.
I'm not going to that fucking woods.
God, they put toothpaste in your clothes.
It's very hard to get toothpaste
off your clothes. Is it? Yeah. Yeah.
You got to really scrub it. Dutch
shit, it doesn't just come off.
So you can't just put it in the washing
machine and it's gone. Well, you know,
we're in the woods to the wash and
close with like literally washboards.
I know it was a camp. We had
archery and shit. There was guns.
They give these little fucking psychos
guns. I was in the archery range. I heard.
I go, what the fuck is that
guy goes a ricochet. I go,
fucking ricochet just came near us.
It's why is someone shooting with
somebody probably hit a rock.
Probably an accident like foc,
little inner city fucking creepers going
to boy scout camp. We'll animals, man,
this is just making me not want to have
kids. I went once, I'm like, I'm good.
It was there for two weeks. Oh
my God. I miss my parents so bad.
Couldn't wait to get home. I was
like, how old are you? Such a bitch.
Um,
I was probably,
it was under 14 so it was
probably the 13 or 1213 oh fuck.
Whose dog? Animals savages and out here
going to boy scouts with cause plus,
you know, 13 or whatever the hell. I was
like, that's fucking young. You know,
you're out there
in the woods with a bunch of fucking
crazy dudes. You don't even know. Like,
Oh yeah, yeah, that's not
good. And this older kids too,
like some of the kids were like 15 1617
and a 17 year old kid and a 14 year old
kids should never be unsupervised.
Yeah.
Especially the 17 year old kids at creep
because they'll just decide that the 14
year old has to do shit, you
know, and then force him to
do it and beat their ass.
It's like, because finally they get
to tell other people what to do.
Like for 17 years their
parents are probably been
telling them what to do and if
they grow up in an abusive household,
you know like salt.
So many bullies that I
met when I was a kid.
It turned out like when you went
to their house you realize, oh,
this guy gets bullied at home and then
he goes and bullies people at school.
Yeah, of course. I think, I think
parenting has a lot to do with it.
The way that people are raised
has a lot to do with it.
I had a friend, these are getting
in fist fights with his dad,
fist fights and he would,
this fucking guy,
I won't say his name because he's
a good dude. He's not a bad guy.
I grew up with him and
he would fight anybody.
Me and my friend Jimmy would go with
this guy and we would have, he goes,
that's it. We're fighting
tonight. And I'm like,
we're fighting tonight because
we're fucking fighting.
And he would just find some money,
like come on mother fucker and there's
fine the guy and start a fight with them.
And I've never met anybody like this.
This guy just would just literally for no
reason go find a person to go. Come on,
motherfucker were fighting
and he would talk about it.
Like he had a good one too. He had a
good left, right? That was like his,
he's wasn't really a very good
fighter who's half decent.
So it wasn't like he was
even winning these fights.
Like a lot of times he'd get in fights
and get his ass kicked. But he had,
he had a pretty decent one too,
but this fucking guy would
just start fights for it.
And then I went to his house and
then I got, became friends with them.
He was friends with my friend Steve.
And when I became friends we hung
around and I realize like, oh,
this guy got fucking abused.
Like he got beat up all
the time like he was,
he would get in like fist fights with
his dad when he was young, you know,
like young, you know [inaudible]
his dad would punch him, you know,
it was like scary shit.
So when you,
when you meet like the monster
behind the curtain and you go, oh,
this isn't so cute anymore.
Isn't it so funny?
Now I know why this guy is doing this.
He's,
he's an asshole because
he's getting bullied.
Because like when I became friends
with like, we never had a fight.
We never even had an argument.
We were really friendly with each other
and for whatever reason it was like he
just would find people that he
wanted to fight and it was just an,
I couldn't understand it. I was like,
why would anybody want to do that?
Until I realized like, oh, this dude
is like fighting his dad all the time.
He's probably fighting his
dad every day. Damn. Okay.
Yes. That's some crazy shit. Shit. Roll
the dice is what it is really is. I mean,
I think about every once in a while I get
kind of down about certain things like,
ah, am I fulfilled at work? Am I happy?
Like, oh, I could be doing better, not,
and then I think about it,
people problem
100%. Right? Like I've been giving, I
haven't been giving Christian a hard time,
but like every once in a while I'll
come home and I'm like in a bad mood and
he's like, what's wrong? And, uh, my,
my problems, such bullshit problems,
you know what I mean?
I have great parents.
I was able to get a good education with
no debt. Like, I have a job that I love.
Like I have friends that I love.
Everything's great.
So like when I tried to put things in
perspective and stories like that really
do put things in perspective
for me, people who don't
have like a home to go to,
people who don't have good parents,
like there's a lot of pain and suffering
out there. You know, I remember, um,
I don't think I told you about this, but,
um, we had gone to San Diego and I tried,
um,
mushrooms and for the first time and uh,
it's like a good,
it's a good way of kind of like
putting things into perspective, right?
Because I felt euphoric. Everything
was great. I had a really,
really good experience with it.
But there was one point when we were like
walking down the street and there was
this one elderly homeless man just
walking and he's like stumbling,
like he can barely walk. Right.
And like, that hit me really hard.
Like this man has such a bad life. Like
he's out on the streets, he's elderly,
he's older than my dad,
you know,
and I think about my dad and he's like
getting up there and like, you know, I,
his body's kind of starting to break
down a little bit and I'm like, man,
this guy, I mean, he has no family.
He has no one looking out for him.
He's out here on the streets and
like, I don't know, like it really,
really hit me and it put everything
in my life in perspective.
Like how freaking lucky I am.
Yeah. It's interesting
that, isn't it funny, it's,
it's kind of says something about people
that it's very in very poor taste to
make fun of poor people unless they're
so poor they don't have a home and then
they're open targets. Yeah.
You know what I'm saying?
Like as far as the way people mock people,
like people will mock homeless people.
Like it's a really common thing to
talk about homeless people on stage,
but if you talk to yeah, yeah, yeah.
Jokes about homeless people are very
common cause homeless people are a lot of
times are crazy. You know,
it's not their fault.
Like one of the reasons why a lot of these
people are homeless because they have
mental illness and there are
undiagnosed or they don't have money for
prescriptions or they
lost their job and they,
sometimes they are diagnosed. But like
if you're a paranoid schizophrenia,
like my friends, a social worker
and she has this one client,
he's this really young, attractive
guy in his twenties. Right.
And he recently got diagnosed as a
paranoid schizophrenia and he is in such
denial about his condition that
he will not get any help. Wow.
And now he's homeless.
He's living in a car. Um,
it's a devastating story and it's
like he has the reasons family has the
resources to help him.
He doesn't want the help.
So what do you do with situations
like that? He's out on the street.
There's not much you can do. And that's
the reality of mental illness. And that's,
it's, it's a weird thing
where like you can't make fun.
No one would make fun of
really poor people, like how
they're poor. But you know,
you could build like, cause fucking
idiot sleeps under a tree, you know,
what do you your sleeping bag and
the fucking park, you'd dip shit.
You don't even have a house really.
Like it could be a point of mockery.
Like people would walk them and even
tell him to fuck off.
Whereas like you would never
do that in a poor neighborhood.
It's kind of strange.
It's like if you reach poverty to the
point of where you don't even have a roof
over your head, you're fair
game. It's weird, right? Yeah.
We have our own way of demonizing poor
neighborhoods though we demonize them by
allowing police brutality in those
areas and justifying it by saying,
well it's a poor area with a lot of
crime so of course the cop can shoot an
unarmed person and not paying the
consequences for you. What is your take,
and I was really interested to talk to
you about this on first of all on the
amount of police brutality
cases that are happening.
Is it just because people were reporting
them now is because people were
recording them now or am I just,
am I just really like only
paying attention to what
gets broadcast in the same
things were always happening.
I think that this is probably something
that's been going on for quite some time,
but now since we have
access to surveillance,
since people are using their smart phones,
since communities are starting to like
really be on edge in regard to the
excessive force, now we're seeing
a lot more coverage about it.
And I think that there's,
there's now a tipping point,
and I don't know if it's going to lead
to a new civil rights movement or what
the outcome will be,
but regardless of what you think about
Michael Brown or Trayvon Martin or any of
these other high profile cases,
I think it's hard to believe that anyone
would watch a video of Eric Garner in
New York City pleading with the cops who
have put him in a headlock to let him
go because he can't breathe.
Right.
And then the cop who kills him doesn't
have to deal any concept or deal with any
consequences for killing him after
putting him in an unlawful headlock.
It's against the law as a cop in New York
to put someone in a headlock like that.
But it didn't matter. He
did it. Eric Gardner dies
and I don't know. Every time
I watched that video, I'm
like, God, just let them go.
Let them go. You know the outcome, but
you keep telling yourself, let them go.
Let them go. Come on. He can't breathe.
He's telling you he can't breathe,
but they didn't fucking let him go
and he's dead. How is that? Okay.
How has that kind of excessive force?
Okay,
and if that's not enough to convince you,
keep in mind that the cops harassing
him because he was selling untaxed
cigarettes, loose cigarettes. Are you
fucking kidding me? You're in New York.
We're talking about Wall Street,
robbing the American people,
destroying the economy, never paying
any fucking consequences for it,
and now you're going to go after
this man because he's selling loose
cigarettes.
It's ridiculous.
That case was really disturbing to me
because I didn't have any cigarettes on
him.
He didn't have anything on him.
No, no. He broke. He broke up a fight.
Cops were called because he
fucking broke up a fight.
It's like that story enrages me.
It really does.
Because even with all of that
evidence of the police wrongdoing,
grand jury verdict says not,
we're not going to indict the cop.
And then you have people that
defend that grand jury verdict.
How do you watch that video and defendant?
Did you actually watch the video?
Did you look into the story or
did you just decide, oh yeah,
it's a poor black guy. You
know, black guys are always
trouble, so fuck it, he died.
Who Cares?
Well, people have this real problem when
it comes to issues like this where they
either go all the way to the right or
they go all the way to the left. Yeah.
And you know the,
the reality of that situation is that
there was no evidence this guy didn't do
anything wrong. He was standing there
had he been arrested before. Yeah,
but so what, what are you saying that
because the guy's been arrested before,
you're allowed to just
fuck with him forever.
And if he's selling loose
cigarettes, that's it. That's
what you're worried about.
Like you're not talking about a guy who's
selling slaves or a guy who's stealing
cars. You're talking about a guy who's
just avoiding a cigarette tax. I mean,
it's so bizarre.
It's so bizarre.
The amount of money you're talking about
is so goddamn minuscule and unimportant
in the city of fucking trillions of
dollars are flowing in and out of it daily
and you're getting this kind of headlock.
He was no lazy
for 50 cents a piece or something
like something. So I mean, yeah,
but when they started grabbing him,
like they didn't need to grab him.
He wasn't doing anything. He wasn't going
anywhere. It wasn't running away. Nope.
They're just grabbing him. And when he was
saying like this, this ends today, look,
y'all always fucking with me.
This ends today. And you're like,
he just looked and I was like,
this is so pointless.
Like shouldn't cop should be worried
about the most important shit first.
Did you solve all the murders? Did
you find all the stolen cars? Do you,
did you solve all the burglaries?
Okay,
let's stop fucking with the
cigarette dude. And let's
just think about that shit.
Like there's only how many people that
are cops. Yeah. What's the number?
This has gotta be more crimes and cops.
It's the only thing that makes sense.
So why the fuck would you
concentrate on this shit?
There's like how many of you
guys, four or five, you know,
I know they came because of a fight,
you know, but what do you think?
They just wanted an extra color because
they got there and decided to arrest
this guy.
I don't know it,
that was one of the more disturbing
stories that we covered because the case
like Trayvon Martin, you know,
you don't have surveillance.
A case like Michael Brown,
you don't have video. So it's,
I can understand even though
I don't agree with them,
I can understand the doubters, right?
But with a case like Eric Garner,
the proof is in the pudding.
It's right in front of you.
You have the video footage and still
there were no consequences for the cops.
And so,
you know,
when you have police departments and
police unions criticizing NFL players for
protesting some of these grand jury
verdicts or protesting some of the actions
of these police officers, I mean you
gotta wonder like what planet they're on.
Like you guys got away with
murder. Okay, let it go.
If people want to protest it,
let it go.
The worst thing you can do is win and
then go out of your way and tell people
that you're offended because
they're upset that you won.
Yeah. What do you, what do you know
the law in terms of what kind of uh,
like the way you're allowed
to grab someone's neck? Like,
no, I don't know specifically, but I
know that that head lock was unlawful,
which is why I don't understand why
there wasn't a grand jury verdict
because here's the reality. What he's
doing definitely is a choke hold.
It was hands are together and his hands
are together in some of the pictures and
some of the pictures he's doing
this where his hands are together.
Technically it's still a choke
hold if you're using one hand,
but there's not nearly the same amount
of leverage as when you're using two
hands. We use to like, this is the real,
like what they call a rear naked choke.
That's what puts you to
sleep really quickly,
but you could still put
a guy asleep like this.
You could put a guy to sleep with a lot
of different ways to grab your hands
once you're grabbing your
hands. So if he's grabbing
his hands, it's a choke hold.
But even if it's a choke hold,
he might not necessarily be choking him.
He might be just holding up and
you're the only one who knows.
That really is that guy,
the guy who did it because either he
or people who are watching because you
either see him really squeezing
down the neck or he's holding on.
He's got the head in here
and he's trapping it,
but he's not putting any pressure on
the neck. Both of them are possible,
but the breathing thing most likely had
to do with this guy being diabetic and
have a lot of health issues. You know
the choking thing, you know you, you,
you can cut a guy's ear off,
you know when you're choking him.
And it is possible because he had his
arm around his neck that was happening.
But it also could have been possible.
The guy was just freaking the fuck out
and these guys were on top of him and
he's having a heart attack.
And either way it was caused
by these guys fucking with him.
So even if their intention
was not to choke this guy out,
even if they grabbed him by the neck,
what you did kill the guy
like for no fucking real,
here's what you should do when
someone tells you I can't breathe,
let off him get off.
But you can't do that
with Psychos, right? No,
you can't let psychos play you say if you,
if you're,
if you're a cop in New York City and
you've got some guy who's like, uh,
you know some football player that's
running a muck and you, you handcuff him,
you're finally drag them to the
rouser who can't breathe, can't Gabby,
you let him up. But he fucking head
butts you and runs through the casino.
You know what I mean?
Like that can happen.
Like you can't really listen to everybody.
This is a camp,
right?
But look,
I have no doubt in my mind that the cops
in that incident knew that Eric Garner
is not a psycho. Okay. I think that they,
that's why they're willing to
engage with them physically,
even though he's a big giant dude.
They knew he was a teddy bear.
I don't know what I'm saying.
Like they knew they got away with it.
Did you notice in the
beginning of the video,
the cop who put him in the choke hold,
like waited for backup before
he attacked Eric Gardner?
So it was like he had it in the back
of his mind like, yeah, I'm gonna,
I'm gonna do what I'm going to do.
I'm just going to make weight and
make sure that I have backup for it.
It's just such a sick video. I mean, for
all the listeners who haven't seen it,
please, please take a
look at it because make
any sense.
Because I think that there's a lot of
people that join the police force that
have great intentions.
And I think that when,
when when you get into situations
where people have what is really pretty
basically ultimate power over other
people, it becomes fucking tricky as hell.
Cause people like to abuse power.
They do,
they get into that sort of a position
and they just take advantage of it and
they do things that they can
justify but aren't morally right.
And this is one of them. It's like
this is not serving or protecting.
What are you guys,
the body guard of the tax collectors is,
that's what the fuck you're doing.
Are we professional leg breakers who are
paid for by the citizens of the United
States? No, you guys are cops. You know,
in the best of the word, you're loyal
and fantastic and a great asset to the
community and a very important aspect of
the community when it comes to keeping
peace and PR, you know, and promoting uh,
like a, a sense of, of
protection. You know,
I have to say though is don't you find
it a little ironic that the NYP d,
the same police force that killed Eric
Garner for selling untaxed cigarettes was
also the same Nyp d that went after
occupy protesters that were protesting
against what Wall Street
did to our economy. How many
people were there though?
How many,
how many,
like how many people were involved
in the occupy Wall Street thing?
Did they just send the cops out there
and just have them start arresting kids
work?
What I found really interesting is JP
Morgan Chase had donated a huge amount of
money,
millions of dollars to the NYP d as The
occupy protest started to get really
fired up. And so look, money talks, right?
Wall Street bankers and the people that
did what they did to our economy in 2008
have money and power.
And so if you have 4.6 million,
if you have blatant, you have that kind
of money, then you by the police force,
they're going to look out for you. Okay,
so when do cops really care about taxes?
They care about taxes. When the
powerless aren't paying their taxes.
How rude is that though? 4.6
million. That is so goddamn blatant.
I mean it is. I remember, I remember
what had happened. I was like, really?
You guys are so transparent.
I mean I got to respect the fact that
you guys are that transparent about it.
Right? I respect that.
That's gangster as fuck.
Just laid out a four point
$6 million cheque. Listen,
I would like to build my bends
into the garage and peace.
You got a big fat cigar was talking to,
I think we could work something out and
you guys need new helmets or some shit.
It's the world we live in, man.
Four point $6 million is like,
that's like saying, you know, look,
we have so much fucking
money that these hippies,
I'm willing to pay 4.6 million just
cleaned this bitch up and they did.
Is it done? There's a, if you go by
there, is there anybody was the square?
Do you know what the square was where
it was Connie, that's what it is.
Is there anybody there anymore?
I don't know if there are occupy
protesters there now, but I mean,
I think it's safe to say at this point
that the occupy movement has died down
considerably. So, which sucks because
I mean, I was very supportive of it.
I was behind it.
I really wanted to keep it alive at the
same time that the banks were doing what
they could to shut it down.
You also had the mainstream media,
which is bought by corporations
also doing its best to discredit it,
be little it. And so you have like
people watching the news thinking,
oh, CNN and Fox News
like this is, you know,
this is a reliable news source thinking
that these occupy protestors or all
these crazy druggies that are living on
the streets and they're causing riots
and there looting and this,
and I mean kind of similar to what
happened with Ferguson protesters,
all of them were painted
as looters in the mainstream press.
Within.
The reality is you have a few crazy
people that might coopt something, right?
That might cause some trouble, but that's
not indicative of all the protesters.
You know? That's not something that
you're going to see with all of them.
It's just like a tiny fringe that
might be causing some trouble.
But it's interesting that
the mainstream press,
we'll focus on those as opposed to the
people who actually have an important
message that they're trying to get out.
I think they just focus on what they
think people are gonna Watch who you're
going to watch. This is the blog and off
the highway, which is by the way you, you,
you guys who are protesting the police,
I get what you're doing.
It's very noble.
There's a lot of like a lot of people
with a lot of really good ideas and a lot
of really positive energy and they, they,
they really want to make some change.
But I just think there's a lot of real
problems and parking off the highway and
one of them is medical care.
People that are sick or people that are
injured for loved ones to lose loved
ones because the highways are blocked off
in the ambulance couldn't get through.
It would be so horrific
and tragic compounding and
already horrific and tragic
situation.
And I don't think it's necessary.
I think there's gotta be a way where you
can allow traffic where regular folks
who probably most of them agree
that police violence is out of hand.
The you shouldn't be just blocking
off highways because you can run into
situations where you cost people
their lives and you cost loved ones.
Loved ones are in horrific grief because
this person didn't get to the doctor
and time and bled out because the
fucking highway was completely shut down
because some white kids wanting
to show how down they were.
They weren't a get arrested
and put zip ties on me, bitch.
I'm going to fucking snapchat this.
I'm going to Instagram these pictures
from the back of this patty wagon.
I'm so down, I'm so down. We're going to
block off the highway. Fuck capitalism.
You know there's a lot of like strong
wills and good intentions and people that
really want the world to
be better than it is today.
That's the motivation behind it all,
but it is very prob problematic when
you do things like stop fellow citizens
from getting places and using traffic
systems and using that just gets weird
man. You don't know what you're,
you're fucking up and if you did,
you would fucking hate yourself.
You can't and you can't
blame it on anybody else. You
can't blame it on the cops.
You can't blame it on Ferguson.
You can't blame it on the president.
If you are blocking the highway
and someone dies because of that,
you have to blame yourself.
You don't need it in your life.
There's other ways to protest.
Yeah. No, I agree with you
about blocking roadways,
but there also is a very delicate balance
because the reality is protests and
political activism is not meant to be
convenient and when it is convenient,
then you don't get heard.
So sometimes you do have to stir the pot.
Sometimes there needs to be
civil disobedience. Right. Uli,
do you think there's a
to do it without blocking
the highway or definitely.
I'm sure. I'm sure there is.
I think it's about white hat
though. What about the city
hall? Sorry to interrupt you,
but what about their city hall? Why
don't they just swarm that? I'm sure.
I'm sure that they did.
I'm sure that they did, but I
don't, I don't know if that's
enough. Really. Um, look,
nothing bothers people in authority more
than having protesters that are causing
a Ruckus.
And by rock is,
I don't mean breaking into
innocent businesses and
looting and doing crazy shit
like that, but there needs to be civil
disobedience right. At a protest,
like the way that protests are supposed
to go down legally as ridiculous.
Like you got to get the right permits
for it and you gotta be in the protest
zone and you, but like the
Burritos, like yeah, let's,
let's put all the protesters in a corner
and ignore them as they're holding
their signs. No, protests are
supposed to be inconvenient.
They're supposed to get
people's attention. It's
supposed to fire people up.
What about this idea?
What about going to city hall and having
so many people show up that you block
the entrances to all the buildings?
I mean,
I'm don't let anybody in you just say,
look to you guys are broken.
This thing's broken. We're not letting
you in. Get the fuck out of here.
It's everybody locks.
And so if you want to get
arrested for blocking the highway,
how about you blocked the real
issue, the real problem, the real,
the real source of government.
And if you did that,
I might be like terrorist
act of suggesting this I
should probably say is don't
do this. I mean, everything's considered,
it's whatever I'm saying. Don't listen.
I know I'm the fear factor host. I'm not
to be taken seriously. Don't do that.
Don't block city hall but, but don't
block the fucking highway. What? I mean,
there's gotta be a way.
Sure there is. And I'm not, you know,
I'm not good at organizing
these types of events, but,
but I think you do make a really good
point about blocking roadways and things
like that. There was a question
I wanted to ask you though.
I'm really curious if you've ever had to
deal with any type of police brutality
as a dude.
No. No. Fortunately, no. I've seen it.
I've seen cops beat the fuck out of
people. Really? Yeah, yeah, I've seen.
But you know, a lot of times it's drunk
assholes and the cops are, you know,
having to protect themselves. I've
seen that too. You know, I've,
I've known a lot of police officers over
the course of my life because my, uh,
dad was a cop and then, uh,
growing up doing martial arts,
I knew a lot of dudes that were cops.
Like from the time I was 14,
15 years old,
I was around cops all the time.
And so, um, I'm just, um, you know,
they, for the most part, I don't look
dangerous. I don't look like a suspect.
And now to this day, now it's easy
because most of them are UFC fans.
Like cops want to learn how
to defend themselves, right?
So I usually just talk to them and
everything's cool. I'm respectful.
But when I was a kid,
I wasn't the one that you'd worry about.
Not a big black guy, you know, I'm
a little white guy, so it's like,
if I was polite, no sir, give
him my license. Registration.
I never had a problem.
But people you know,
in the worst situation can
react in the worst way.
And that includes cops. I mean, who,
you don't know what the fuck that cop
had to do before he got to you that day.
He could have been in some sort of crazy
situation where someone's trying to run
him over with a car and he pulls out
a meth head off an old lady or just
ultimate chaos.
He could've gone to a domestic violence
situation where you saw somebody get
shot, you know, by the
time a cop gets to you,
who the fuck knows what he
saw right before you or just
in the years before you.
Yeah. So they could be really high
strung and yeah. You know, and I, I,
I think that some people
don't recognize that.
And I also think that the idea of being
a cop is probably ridiculous and almost
no one's qualified to
do it for a long time.
Cause I think the amount of stress that
they see or they experienced in the
amount of violence that they
see is almost, you know, it's,
it's in a lot of ways it's,
it's crazy than being a soldier because
some of these guys are putting in 25
years,
I can't imagine it.
I really can't.
Some of them are seeing all kinds of
crazy shit for year after year after year.
It's like that becomes their reality. It
changes like who they are. I've never,
I mean I've never seen
a dead body in my life,
but cops see that kind of
stuff on a regular basis.
So I don't want to discredit cops out
there that are doing good work and I know
they exist.
But I think it's also important for
them to speak out against the police
brutality that they see.
I think a lot of the reason why people
are kind of opposed to police in general
is because the good cops are usually very
reluctant to speak out against the bad
cops and they protect one another.
And so I think it's important for the
good cops to speak out against them
because the bad cops are the
ones that are really, you know,
muddying the waters and um,
tainting the entire police force.
You're right.
And I think there's a really accurate
representation of what a bad cop really is
when you just look at it. Don Imus
posters on the Internet. I think that,
and you get a number of people,
I don't know how many cops there are that
are professional police officers today
in the United States of America,
but just whatever that number is,
if 2% of them are fucking douchebags,
which is really likely when you take a
hundred regular people just a hundred,
the odds of you having to is
pretty good. It's probably 70, 80%.
The odds of you having one douche bag
out of a hundred people's a 100% so it's
at least 1% douche bag and every
hundred unless you're in like boulder or
something where sue people
are just super sweet.
Unless you're in some weird place,
you're going to have like one out of
a hundred people that are douche bags.
That's going to be the case
with police officers as well.
So if you look at Internet comments like
especially like how many people tell
you to sit on their
face and shit like that.
Look at all the assholes
that are out there,
but then compare it to the amount
of people that are out there.
They're dealing with some insanely
incomprehensible number of people that are
online right now. So for hundreds
of millions just in this country,
just throwing information back and forth
in the shitty stuff gets through the
net and it hits you and you're
like, people fucking suck. No,
most people are awesome.
The vast majority of people are great.
The vast majority,
but it's just like one or 2% that
sneak through that fuck the whole thing
sideways. Yeah, definitely.
There's no question about,
that happens with cops too.
I think cops are representative of the
general public as a whole. And if you,
if you looked at only the shitty web
comments and ignored all the people that
are like posting Facebook posts on
each others walls, you look so awesome.
I'm so psyched for you. You guys
this shit. I love you to death.
All that positive shit that people do
back and forth with each other that that's
like, that counts too. And
we don't focus on that.
Where it was focusing on these
assholes opened litter too. You know,
these is shit hoods, right?
The angry things and you
fucking good for the season.
Huh? You know this asshole's calls,
you're always going to have assholes.
When I think about like my
Instagram page for instance, right?
Like I get a lot of love on Instagram.
Like I very rarely we'll get like a
terrible comment on there and, and I've,
I love people who follow me on Instagram.
They're super sweet, super nice,
really respectful. Every once in a while
I'll have to block someone, but it's not,
it's very rare. Um, so yeah,
I think I should focus on that as
opposed to like the crazy ass people that
write terrible things on youtube, which
just the sheer numbers, it's like true.
We get caught up in a few variables,
a few people that get that
sneak through the net.
And I think with cops for we,
we,
we've already established it's
an insanely difficult job.
It's really hard for people
to process all the stress.
It's not something the
average person experiences.
And it's also therefore not something the
average person can commiserate with or
understand or even conceptualize.
If you're not seeing
people shot all the time,
like you've never seen a body and
you're talking to a guy who works in the
fucking gang unit like Jesus
Christ, you know, you're,
you're dealing with two
completely different realities.
And I think there's that.
And then there's also the 2% thing,
like you get a hundred people, you know,
there's more than a hundred cops. One
of them's a con. All right, he's just,
he's an asshole. There's no, it doesn't
mean that all cops aren't like that.
And the other problem is when you're
around cons and you've got this fucking
code of silence and you know,
even if it's one con out of a hundred,
if he's got away with some shit,
you want to get away with some shit too.
They were all brotherhood and the fucking
badge and that's where bad cops come
from.
That's where all that,
there's a lot of them have good intentions
when they get involved and then they
slowly but surely get corrupted.
I think it's a culture problem within
police enforcement and it needs to be
addressed.
And one way that you can address it is
ensuring that prosecutors and district
attorneys and other people that are in
the justice system aren't in bed with
cops. So when they do do
something wrong, you know,
there are proper consequences, you
know, in response to what they've done.
Um, but it's interesting because I never
thought for a million years that I would
ever experience like a bad cop,
you know,
cause I'm not the demographic that usually
deals with crooked cops. Right? I'm,
you know, white girl, you know,
who is driving a nice car
and I am very agreeable,
very nice with cops. Whenever they pull
me over. I think you're a white crow,
but if you were trying to date some
dude who's a white dude
in Wisconsin and you can't
Armenia. Interesting. That's true.
That's true. Yeah. I'm not, yeah,
I'm not late earlier white girl.
You're in some weird category.
Um, but it was funny like
a few weeks ago. Really.
I mean, it's not a bad thing. I love
Armenians. Armenians are firing people.
I love our Armenian fighters are some
of the most exciting fighters to watch.
Yeah, super aggressive.
I don't believe it.
Breezy and Manny ganbare and some of the
most fun guys to watch animals. Yeah,
they really are toward
Moosejaw and other Armenian.
There's a lot of top fighters
that Armenian. I didn't
know that. Oh yeah. Okay.
A good percentage. Yeah.
That's good to know. Animal.
Yeah. Is quite a few of them.
Quite a few of them because
they're known for kickboxers too.
A lot of good Armenian kickboxers.
That's cool. I like that
to an Armenian sweet 16 right after this.
So I'm looking forward to that.
We're going to eat it. Don't do any
sparring food. Don't, I won't, I won't,
I won't just can throw, I won't
mess with them. Um, but yeah,
like I got pulled over by a cop a few
weeks ago because I did something wrong.
I made an illegal uturn and I knew like,
I remember right before I did it,
I had two of my colleagues in the,
in the car with me right before no,
three of them right before I did it,
I looked around and I was like,
is there a cop? Is there a
cop? Nope, I'm going to do it.
So I start doing the u turn and a
cop turns the corner and I was like,
dammit, okay, whatever. I'm going to get
a ticket. It's fine. I deserve it. Right.
And I'm not combative or anything
pulls me over before he says,
do you know why I pulled you over?
Right.
Which is what they usually say when they,
I believe me,
I've gotten a lot of tickets. First thing
he says to me is, why are you laughing?
And I wasn't, I wasn't laughing.
I'm about to get a ticket, right?
And I don't want to get a ticket.
I just tinted my windows illegally.
I'm probably gonna get a ticket for that
on the Internet.
Everything's gonna be fine. Um, and
so I'm, I'm not laughing, right?
And so I look at him, I'm like, I'm
sorry officer. I'm not laughing.
If it seems as though I have like
any type of amuse look on my face,
it might be because I just did something
really stupid and I can't believe I did
something stupid. And I
really apologize. He's like,
I can give you four tickets right now.
I'm gonna give you four tickets.
And I was like, okay. He's like,
yeah. He's like, yeah. He's like,
do you deserve for tickets?
And I was like, um, if I'm,
if I did four things wrong,
then I guess I deserve for tickets.
I was just being so agreeable with him.
Right. I'm like, I'm sorry officer.
I apologize him like 50,000
times. And then, you know,
he just like stood there and
yelled at me and then finally, oh,
and then it wasn't,
you know,
I had just gotten the car so I
hadn't gotten my license plates yet.
And he's like, where are your license
plates? And I was like, it's a new car I,
I haven't gotten before I
could even finish the sentence.
It's like, I don't care.
Like he was just really mean. And I was
like, Oh, do this guys. Like roid it up.
I don't know what his issue
is. He's pissed. Right.
But I'm just going to keep
agreeing with him and let it go.
The story gets better.
That's just the beginning.
So then he goes back to his car and gets
his little citation booklet thing and
he, I don't know what he looks up, maybe
he looks up my identity or whatever.
And then all of a sudden I hear him
say something and I couldn't hear him
because it's kind of a busy road. And so
I look at my, my coworkers and I'm like,
did he say something to me?
They're like, we don't know.
We didn't hear him right and they were
like spooked out because this guy was
being such a dick.
And then he said something again
and I still couldn't hear him.
So I like poked my head out the window
and I was like, I'm sorry officer,
I couldn't hear you. Can you please
repeat that? And then he was like,
I need you to step out of the vehicle.
And I don't know what it
was about him saying that,
but I immediately freaked out.
Okay.
And so like I start tearing up and I'm
trying to hold it back and I'm like,
why does he want me to get out of
the cars? He going to search it.
There was nothing in the car,
but I'm like, I did search a car.
I know have some sort of a warrant.
And also he needs probable cause to
have me to have me step out of the car.
There was no reason for him to
have me step out of the car.
That alone was not a lawful requests.
But anyway, I stepped out of the car,
I went by him.
And then I realized very quickly that
this cup is a fucking pervert. Okay.
And so as I'm crying,
he's getting a rise out of this and
he starts asking me like a bunch of
questions, like, why were you using
your phone when you were driving?
And I was like, my phone was in my
purse and my purse was in the backseat.
I wasn't using the phone.
He's like,
how often do you use the phone when
you're driving? I was like, never. And,
and I was like, I would never do
that. I know that I made the u turn,
I deserve the u turn ticket, please give
it to me and I'm, I'm going to go to,
it's like, where were you
going? And I was like,
I was just trying to go back to
work. And he's like, he was like,
when was the last time you deserved a
ticket? And I was like, what the fuck?
Where's this guy going with this?
Right. And then finally he was like,
where do you work?
And I was very close to work,
so I pointed down the street where
our offices are. And then he was like,
he was like, what do you do for
work? Oh No. Yeah. He's like,
what do you do for work? And I was
like, oh, I'm a reporter. Right.
I don't want to get into the details. Like
I'm actually an internet commentators.
Like what? I just said reporter.
And then he was like, he's like, oh,
there's a newspaper company down the
street. He was like an older cop,
I don't know. And I was like, no, I
work for a show called the young Turks.
It's an online new show. It's the
largest online news show in the world.
You had to tell him is
the largest fucking stats.
I mean, got to keep it real. He's
got to know what he's, you know,
and then he asks me, what are you going
to report on this little incident today?
Oh God. And then I was like, nothing.
I don't report on my personal life.
And then he slowly closes
aside citation book and he's,
and then he says, are you upset or
no? He's like, are you disappointed?
He use the word disappointed.
Are you disappointed that I'm
letting you off with a warning?
And I didn't know what to say. Like, do I
tell him yes because I deserve a ticket,
please give me a ticket officer, or do
I tell him no, I'm not disappointed.
I'm actually fucking stoked because I
don't want to pay hundreds of dollars for
this ticket.
So at first I didn't say anything at all.
I'm just standing there looking
pathetic and I'm crying.
I'm literally crying at this point. Right.
And then he was like, did you hear me?
He's like, are you disappointed that
I'm letting you off with a warning?
And I was like, no, I'm not
disappointed. And then he's like,
I hope you have a better day.
And then that was it.
It was the creepiest interaction I've
had with a cop. Do you think you crazy?
Um, no. I used to, but I don't
think I crazy anymore, but,
and I wasn't crying until he
told me to step out of the car.
That's a weird request. Yeah, that's
a, that's a power move for sure. Yeah.
Not a threat. He didn't do
anything dangerous. You're not.
I was the most criminal activity.
I told him I deserve the ticket.
I gave him my license, my
registration, I did nothing wrong.
There was no reason for him to
have me step out of the car. None.
That's the power trip part that everybody
hates about cops. Yeah, there's you,
you will run into people like
that every now and again.
You know,
they have so much power and in that
moment you feel so defenseless. Right?
So you,
for someone like me who like I
hate admitting this about myself,
but sometimes in cases like that
I will cave into authority. Right?
I like to question authority,
but in a situation like that,
I'm not questioning authority.
I'm doing exactly what he wants me to do.
I'm doing, I feel powerless. Right.
So now that I think about it,
in retrospect, I get angry because I
wish I would've handled it differently.
I wish I would have gotten
his badge number. I wish I
would have gotten his name.
I wish I would have been able to do a
report on it on our show and actually be
like, hey, this is a cop from Culver
city and this is what he did. Right?
But I didn't think about it in the moment
because I was so scared and I felt so
powerless. I don't know.
It was a crazy experience.
Okay, so here, here's
why that's disturbing.
This is turban cause
you're this very powerful,
intelligent,
like outspoken person.
You speak regularly online to untold
millions of people worldwide in these
videos.
And yet in this one interaction,
you were so taken aback by this carbon.
So scare that you were
crying and in in you,
you didn't get this guy's badge number.
You didn't get this guy. Who are you?
Who has the recourse?
You,
who has the vehicle for delivering
this information all over the world and
exposing this real thing that
you went through, you didn't.
So now imagine a girl who's insecure,
a girl who was terrified
of public speaking,
a girl who maybe has had some sort of
a weird background that you grew up and
she's in that sort of the same situation.
She runs into that same asphalt.
Yeah, no, I, I can't
even imagine it. I can't,
yeah,
I mean they would be like shaking and
weeping at freaking the fuck out and this
guy gets off on that.
I mean that's,
that's really what you're dealing with
and it shows how effective it is that it
works on you cause you're not a pussy. No,
I'm not saying that to a truck. Yeah, you
can say,
you can say to me,
I'm not going to be offended by it was
the wrong thing. So you can call. Yeah,
you can say it's like too confusing.
It's like too many variables.
You're not a coward. Not at all. You're
you, you confront things and so for,
for you to be freaked out by it,
it should really sort of highlights what
a confrontational situation that is and
how it can really be a problem.
And there were a lot of
factors that played a role.
Not only was there the
power imbalance there,
but there was also the fact that he was
just this huge cop that was towering
over me as I was standing there in front
of him and I felt so small and I felt
like he was so angry for no freaking
reason that I was so scared that if I said
the wrong thing, that he might do
something to me. You know? Even though,
even though my cohort,
there were three coworkers in the car
after it all happened, they were like,
that sounds insane. Cops will like
literally like a really bad cop.
Literally put himself in a situation
where you put your hand up to stop him and
if you touch him,
that's assault and then they grab you
and throw you to the ground. I mean,
I've seen a scared,
that's why I was so scared.
I didn't know what he was going to do,
but he definitely got off on me standing
in front of him weeping like that.
He definitely got off on the fact that
I recognize that there was an imbalance
of power there. And I
don't know, like I, again,
I think about it in retrospect and it
makes me so angry and in the moment I was
so powerless vigilante and just go
running red lights to funds, motherfucker.
I mean I would love to son of a bitch,
I wish I could identify
him and I don't know,
get some sort of justice, but
imagine, think about that.
Think about the relatively minuscule
amount of discomfort I felt in that
situation compared to what
other people deal with.
I mean, think about how powerless
and how angry those people are.
And so when you have angry protesters,
right,
that are responding to Ferguson or
Eric Garner and all those other things,
and then they have the media tell them,
you guys are too violent,
you need to calm down, can you understand
why they'd be so angry? Oh, for sure.
Yeah,
I mean it totally makes sense that they
would want to do something as disruptive
as stopping the highway traffic.
And it certainly does move
the conversation because
people have to address it.
And it may be so impactful that cops
might actually think twice before they
squeeze a trigger because they don't
want more craziness and more Russians of
violence and or rather a
protest, not violence. In fact,
cops actually doing the van,
you see that,
that one undercover cop that
got busted and he, he had a gun,
he was pointing at the guy
taking a picture because
they were causing violence.
There were doing shit,
you know, like they,
they've done this tactic
for the longest time.
Like one of the ways that they can stop
protest is they use what's called agent
provocateurs and agent provocateurs
or someone who looks like a regular
protester.
But what
they are is police officers or military
or people they hire and they go in and
they'll wear bandanas and cover their
face and shit and they'll start smashing
things.
They'll smash windows and they'll turn
things into looting riot type situation
so that the cops have reason to move in
with force and start arresting people.
And that's how they
stop a peaceful protest.
And it's so creepy that this is a tactic
that has been used for a long time and
it was always like one of those conspiracy
theory, tin foil hat, stupid things,
and then we realized, oh no, these
motherfuckers really do this.
It happens. Yeah. I remember the first
time I had heard about agent provocateurs,
I was like, come on guys.
How conspiratorial and
loony is that? So loony,
and then I realized it
was happening with occupy.
I realized that it was happening
with recent protests and it's just,
I love how they try to discredit
peaceful protest by doing that,
by coming in and looting and,
and starting violence and making it
seem as though all of the protesters are
violent. Because again, the mainstream
media is going to latch onto that.
And you're right. I think that that's
definitely better to drum up ratings.
I mean, if you're going to do a
news report on a peaceful protest,
is that going to do well with ratings?
Probably not.
If you're going to do coverage of looting
and violence that's taking place, um,
in relation to the protest,
people are going to be,
they're going to get fired up,
they're going to get angry and they're
going to start referring to these
protesters as animals and all that.
I mean, I've seen so much of that,
but don't you see a resistance to people
doing stories on the actual undercover
cops? He got busted pointing the gun
100%. I don't see anything on that.
I didn't see anything on that on CNN.
I didn't see anything on that,
on any of the coverage of the La riots.
I was like,
do you guys not understand
what's going on here?
CNN is probably still reporting
on the missing plane. I mean, see,
I don't know where CNN is right now.
These, these riots in Oakland rather not
la. Um, they, they were so fucking crazy,
man. These kids took over highways.
There's a lot of them, you know,
in a lot of them got arrested and the
to see that photo of that guy pointing a
gun at the camera man, who's, who's
pretending to be a protest. I was like,
what the fuck is going on?
Yeah. Like this is crazy.
You guys are pretending to be protestors.
You're smashing a window.
You get paid tax dollars to smash windows
tax dollars. They get paid tax dollars
to undermine a political process,
a democratic process
and turn it violence so they can come
and arrest people. That's amazing.
It's so bizarre. So bizarre. You
know, one other thing, those bizarre,
I saw a lot of people that were quote
unquote progressive's are quote unquote,
you know,
really leftwing strong left wing people.
And they were in at least
an if not an agreement.
They were, they were, um,
at least understanding of the people
who looted and smashed windows.
And one on one guy went to his,
his Twitter page and he had this crazy
statement like if people respect you,
they'll respect your,
obviously people didn't respect this place
and it was like an h and r block with
a brick through its window. I was
like, what are you doing? Like,
well this is crazy. Like Starbucks
is there smashing Starbucks is
for corporations. No, I can't stand that.
I mean that really does undermine attract
people from what the real message is.
The looters are not doing any
great service to the protest.
Question is how many of those looters
are cops? How many of them don't know?
I know many people who
are like strong super
recipe bar getting caught up in the
momentum that was actually kicked off by
vigilante cops or even
provoq agent provocateur
tour cops. Yeah, that would
be hilarious. And you know,
going back to the whole
journalism angle of it,
I mean that's what the great thing
about investigative journalism would be.
If we had strong investigative
journalists in this country,
they would take that beat and they would
go to these protests and investigate
and try to figure out how many agent
provocateurs there are out there. Right.
But we don't have that anymore.
And that's what's scary.
It's scary when you can only refer to
a few people in the country as good
journalists like Matt Taibbi,
Michael Hastings at one point.
Unfortunately he's not
here anymore. Um, you know,
the Jeremy Ski Hills of the world,
I dunno.
Yeah. I don't know either. And we,
we live in a very unique
and interesting time of, uh,
expanding possibilities.
So it's, it's cool.
It's cool to be a part of it
and watched it all going down.
But it's interesting trying to
see it sort itself out, you know,
has everything's going on, but
it's, it's hopeful to me. Uh,
I'm very hopeful,
you know,
even though there's a lot of
fucked up shit in the world,
I think that when I see
these like Oakland protests,
even though I don't agree
with shutting down highways,
I love the fact that there's this many
people that are pissed off at the way
things are going.
Even if they're misguided in,
in some way or overzealous in some way,
they're their,
their intentions are the correct type of
intentions because they recognize that
we have a kind of a wacky system.
Yeah. You know, and, and I,
I think not enough attention is put on
the idea of cops and the idea of being a
cop being this insanely fucking
difficult thing to manage.
It's one of the reasons why
you see so much violence.
He sees that cop that was busted in
Denver who had the guy on the ground,
he was punching him in the face and
the wife came over, she was pregnant,
they trip the wife and she fell
down and no, I didn't see. Oh.
And then they took the guy's camera and
erase the picture of race, the video.
But he had already
uploaded it to the cloud.
So this guy got on the news with
this video of this cop jazz,
fucking throwing haymakers at this dude's
face. You know, it's just, come on man,
you don't have, there's no need to do
that. You don't have to do that. You're,
you're doing some, if you wanted
to arrest someone for a crime,
you don't have to punch him in the face.
I don't even fighting back. It is crazy.
Yeah.
I guess the only upside of
it is the political activism
that's coming out of it.
Um, but it's, it's funny
because, you know, you're
mentioning how you're hopeful,
but I feel like society keeps devolving.
Like it gets worse and worse and now we
have this whole situation like, you know,
not to do a stark transition,
but now we have like this ridiculous
situation with Sony and like the and,
and how we have Kim Jong,
Ooh.
And dictating what kind of
creative freedom we have
here in this country. I mean,
that kind of stuff is coming out
now and you're just like, really?
Is there really hope in this country
right now? If the interview goes down,
what hope could there possibly be?
It's not even about the interview going,
it's a Seth Rogen movie and they're not
going to put it in the movie theater.
We should just fucking move to the woods.
We should all just give up and
civilization. James Franco,
James Franco's in that mirror
to using that movie as well.
So this is a double disaster. This is
a huge box office head off the bat.
It's going to be number one
the first week it comes out.
It's all strategically planned.
Isn't that the best part of the story
that a freaking comedy movie featuring
Seth Rogen and James Franco is what
caused like this ridiculous hack and it's
what cause like the North
Korean government to be up
and I was like, I get it.
The storyline can be a little
offensive to your dictator, right?
If it has to do with assassinating
him their dear leader. Right.
But like I feel like this entire story
in this entire situation is full of
pussies. Right? Oh God,
this is fucking crazy.
Armenian Bra came in here,
but it's true. It's true.
You have policies on one side
with Sony backing down from,
from the movie you have supposedly North
Korean pussies that are so offended by
a movie. They're like, oh my God,
how dare you offend our dear leader.
We're going to go after you.
I mean all around just a bunch of people
that are scared and I get the email
hack was devastating for Sony.
A lot of private information,
embarrassing information was leaked to
the press. Right? But at the same time,
like you,
you can't let a dictator of a country
like North Korea make decisions about what
your company should district distribute
as a movie. Like it's ridiculous. No,
Bama said it,
which I thought was amazing.
I go bomb was commenting on
a movie being distributed.
It should become an international affair.
It really has.
I don't know how this is gonna end up,
but one thing that I will say is I'm not
going to believe the feds that this is
100% in North Korea is doing.
Like for some reason I find
it inconceivable that it's
a bunch of hackers from
North Korea doing this 14 year old kid
in Australia, in his underwear right now,
laughing his ass off.
I was thinking about that yesterday.
It's speculation and I have
no evidence to prove it right.
But like a lot of these hackers are like
teenagers and they're really smart and
they're really savvy and sometimes
they're not even smart and savvy.
Sometimes people are really stupid with
their passwords and all they have to do
is guess, and the hackers will get
into their email and that's it. Right?
Reality is if someone can
break into your system,
if you haven't found that someone
isolated them and arrested them,
then you don't know who the fuck they
are. Okay. You just don't. So if you're,
if you're just taking any old
threat from someone like that,
and it's saying it's Kim Jong Moon
and you're not giving us any reason to
believe you, we got, well, I don't
know. I don't know if you're right.
You might be right. It could be him.
I mean, he's got 1800 cyber warriors.
They're there. They're ready to rock
and roll a fucking any given time.
They're all in line that goose step
over to their desks and at least start
fucking people up all over
the world for the dear leader.
And it's also kind of amazing that like
in this day and age where we've given up
so much of our individual liberty,
our freedoms in the name
of national security,
all we need is one anonymous threat,
that there would be another
nine 11 type attack.
And then we back out of like showing
a movie. I mean, think about it.
Think about how we're all spied on
indiscriminately on a daily basis. Okay.
Think about the fact that you know,
after nine 11 we gave away so many of
our rights because we were so afraid of
these big bad terrorist and the government
supposed to be keeping us safe, right?
The CIA supposed to be
on top of everything.
Our intelligence is supposed to be top
of the line and all it takes is one
anonymous threat and people are like
tucking tail and hiding behind the bed.
Isn't that the fault? I mean,
or I shouldn't say the fault,
isn't that the decision
though of the company itself?
Because Obama himself has said that
he thinks that it was a mistake.
So it really doesn't matter whether or
not the CIA protects anybody or whether
or not the FBI, they, it was their
choice. Yeah. It never moved past that.
So I don't think it's in that situation.
I think it's fair to blame like
the CIA or any of those people.
It's just like they decided
to pull it out. Oh, Mama
told them that was a mistake.
No, no, I, I agree with you
on that. But at the same time,
like aren't we supposed to have certain
agencies within our government that know
everything because they're
spying on everyone?
This is the reality in
argument for it, right? No,
this is actually an argument against
it because they spy on so many goddamn
people that are completely innocent
that their systems are just like full of
information and data. That's
absolutely useless. Okay. So the,
that's one of the biggest issues
that I have with this. Um,
I interviewed Laura Poitras's on a
show called take part live and she was
getting into detail about that,
about how the way that we
collect intelligence right
now is actually the most
ineffective way because we're collecting
so much data on people that are totally
innocent.
So how do you sift through all of
this data and determine whether or not
someone's an actual threat?
Yeah. How do you, do they have, uh, the,
the building it like building
a storage facilities,
hoping they'll have better
search mechanisms in the
future? Is that the idea?
I have no idea. But what they're
doing right now isn't working. I mean,
when you have something like the Boston
bombing and you have like terrorist
attack, I mean, look, we, we don't have
terrorists attacks here all the time.
You know what I mean?
Like despite the fear mongering that
you see in the mainstream media, um,
it's just fear mongering,
right?
But every once in a while when you do
have some sort of event like the Boston
bombing, it's like,
well, I don't know NSA.
You've been collecting all this
information on everyone and you have these
people that are posting things online,
talking about how they
want to kill Americans and
plotting to do certain things.
How come you didn't catch these guys?
Well,
like why is it that you guys are focusing
so heavily on the type of porn people
are, but you're not focusing heavily on,
you know, the real threats that are out.
Well,
that's where it's a real shame when you've
got a bunch of agent provocateurs at
occupy Wall Street where nothing
bad is happening. That's,
that's where it's a shame. It's like, I
don't know who, what agency they're from,
whether or not they could be involved with
some sort of a terrorist activity, uh,
investigation unit.
But if you,
if you wasted resources looking after
hippies and a drum circle and that could
have possibly saved somebody's life,
he we're going to be like really
understandably pissed off,
which is one of the things about this
agent provocateur thing in Oakland,
the piss people off. It's like, come
on. Yeah, we're paying for that.
We actually pay for that.
Our taxes.
Every citizen contributes to the payroll.
I mean that's crazy.
They're paying you guys to undermine
us and you guys to break windows and
pretend you're fucking bad protesters
and tried to start people looting so that
you can get come in and sweep them into
the paddy wagon and fulfill quotas.
That's the weirdest thing.
Like what the fuck would they do if we
all collectively as a country decided we
will not break any laws for 30 days,
they'll probably frame us.
They would have to start framing us. We,
their budgets would fall apart there.
They're fucking departments would fall
apart when it came time to like budget
meetings and shit. Well we've had no
crime since 19 blah, blah, blah blah.
Why do you think a police enforcement
for the most part is against legalizing
marijuana or legalizing drugs in general?
It's because they will be out of jobs.
I mean, there will still be crime,
obviously,
but when you look at our incarceration
rate and how we incarcerate more people
than any other country in the world,
it's because of drug laws and there
is a lot of profit to be made off.
The prohibition of marijuana.
Cops make money off of it
that keeps them in business.
Correctional officers remain in business.
Private prisons remain in business.
There's a lot of money behind prohibition.
Yeah. Stopping people from doing
things that they want to do. Yeah,
that doesn't hurt you is ridiculous
and it's some daddy shit.
You're your daddying people. You're
telling them what they can and can't do,
and then I include things that I'm
totally opposed to like cigarettes.
I think cigarettes are
the dumbest way to die.
It just drives me crazy when I see
good friends who have a problem with
cigarettes and they can't kick it. I'm
like, I'm watching you poison yourself.
Like this is so stupid,
but I'm 100% in favor.
You'd be able to do it if you
want to do it. Same here. Fuck.
Who is anybody to tell another
person what they can't do.
It's one thing to tell a person,
don't commit a crime or don't
commit assault or don't harm people,
but that's the number one problem with
the government telling you that anything
is illegal, whether it's mushrooms
or prostitution or anything.
It says who says who.
Look,
that's one of the reasons why I'm in
favor of legalizing things and regulating
them with common sense regulations.
So like with prostitution,
legalize and regulate it.
Okay,
so these people can say it's safe when
they're trading sex for money with drugs,
obviously I'm not saying, hey,
this is a wild, wild west,
let's legalize everything
and not have any regulations.
And that's usually what are like,
that's the type of argument
that pro prohibition people
will say, right? Like, Oh,
if you legalize it,
all of a sudden like 10 year olds are
going to be smoking pot. No they're not.
No they're not.
We have laws put in place to make sure
that 10 year olds aren't drinking alcohol.
You do the same thing with marijuana.
There's also an issue with a,
there's not an issue of public opinion
because public opinion is very important,
but there is an issue with needing 50%
or more of the people to agree in order
to give you freedom. Like, Whoa,
Whoa, Whoa, Whoa, whoa, Whoa, whoa.
It's not that hard to trick.
Half the people,
they have mortgages and fucking softball.
They have to get their kids
dressed for and there, you know,
it's not that hard to trick people about
stories of brain damage and memory loss
and men Bra and tits,
that there's plenty of fake data that
you can bandy around in court and,
and, and people could get
confused. So 50% is not good.
50% is not a healthy number.
What it should be.
Let's find out first what
category we put these laws in.
Here's a category. Does it hurt
anybody else? No. Okay. So let's,
let's, this is a personal choice
category. Yes. So it should,
it doesn't even have to be 1% right.
This is what it should be.
How many people are opposed to it and
what are your reasons for being opposed to
it and are they rational and are they
based on the data we currently are aware
of? Yeah. And if they're not, they're
not valid. And you need to say like,
do you believe that marijuana makes you
grow tits? Do you believe that marijuana,
cause I had like some lady,
she was telling me testicular cancer,
I'm like what are you talking about?
Yeah. Or read it online. Like no, you did
must making this up. Well and also if
you've read it online, it must be true
person. My point is, could vote on it.
If they went to the ballot and they go,
Oh fuck that.
I don't want my children hooked on.
We click and they hit that there. Their
vote, whether informed or not. It's valid.
And I think you should
have to prove that your,
your point in some way is informed.
Well, one, that's one of the
issues with ballot initiatives. Um,
not only are people either uninformed,
but they're also misinformed a lot of
times because there's a lot of money
behind the advertisements that are
either for or against ballot initiatives.
Right.
And the thing that amazes
me about political ads is
politicians can straight out
lie. Yeah. Political action committees
can straight out lie in any political ad.
And why is it that when it comes to an
advertisement for a product like beer for
instance, right? Like if Samuel
Adams was to advertise right now,
like our beer is going to give you super
powers and you're gonna all of a sudden
lose 20 pounds and like they can't
do that. It's false advertising.
Why is it the politicians are able to
falsely advertise whatever the hell they
want?
It's probably because
they're the gatekeepers and
they're the ones who get to
decide whether or not
something is illegal.
But I've seen so many political ads
where I'm like, that's not true.
That's not true. Why are they
able to say this? That's amazing.
So with ballot initiatives, if
there's money behind, you know,
there's legalized bribery
behind a lot of it. Um,
there's a lot of misinformation
behind a lot of it.
And if you're not someone who sits
down and analyzes political news all day,
it's very easy for you to be misinformed.
And that's not your fault.
It's because of the system and
how it's set up against you. Yeah.
And it's also known as an
incentive to change it, to
make it even. Yeah. You know,
why would we do that?
Let everybody wait a bit.
We're going to make less money
and what else is going to happen?
There's going to be less jobs
They're going to have some power. Fuck.
It's the same thing with climate change.
I mean, people immediately go to Oh, less
jobs and that's all I really care about.
I've had conversations with
that, with people about that.
When they see, um, the, uh,
all the oil work that do end up in Canada,
that devastation to the environment around
it. And you're like looking at photos,
you're like, Holy Shit. And people are
like, oh, relax. It's just a little bit,
because so many jobs are
dependent upon that. They're very,
very sensitive to people criticizing it.
If you don't know,
if you're not from around there,
I mean they,
that's like a major source of income
for a lot of folks up there and I
understand it because that's
your livelihood and you
don't want anyone messing
with their livelihood,
which is why it's so important for the
federal government to invest in renewable
energy because then you transfer the jobs,
you know,
from dirty coal and whatever the hell
we're doing to renewable energy sources.
New Jobs can be created,
but we're not even willing to have that
conversation because right now we're
stuck on this ridiculous debate as to
whether or not climate change is manmade
or not.
Why are we having that debate?
Why are we having that
debate drives me crazy.
I think we need to work
in la for sure on solar.
It's so ridiculous that we live in a
place that's literally sunny 300 days a
year and if you fly over it, you don't
see a single solar panel. It's crazy.
I know that the expense of the
technology is right now it's pretty high,
but I guarantee within
the next decade or so,
it's gonna drop down to some sort of
a manageable point where people will
consider installing them on the
top of every building. Yeah,
you've got free electricity. I mean, it's
gotta be worth something. It's even if,
even if it's not 100% of
your electrical output,
it's probably like high forties 50 I mean,
I don't know,
but as they get better at these things,
I mean they figured out some new,
it's like a spray on panel that you can,
they can take electricity from, from
the air spray on solar panels. Shut up.
Really? Yeah. Yeah, yeah. Amazing.
There's all kinds of new, is that every,
they're fully transparent solar cell that
could make every window and screen up
power source. Jesus fucking
Christ. That's amazing. I love it.
God Damn geniuses that
dance around amongst us.
We're mere apes. We are mere Abe's.
We were mere apes. We really are.
That someone figured out a way to make
glass power up your fucking TV. No,
I know.
I should have this conversation.
I've had these like
philosophical conversations
with Jank on our post game show
for our members and like I'm probably the
post like pessimistic self deprecating
person on the planet because oftentimes
in our post game shows I have like these
like quarter life crises where I talk
about how I'm a failure and how I haven't
done anything meaningful with my life.
I mean think about like you see stuff
like that.
You see these like astrophysicists and
these neuroscientists and all these
amazing intelligent people
and you're like, what do I do?
I just read the news and I comment on it.
You know,
and that sounds very self deprecating,
but it's true.
Like I wish I could do
something that actually changes.
It changes the world like that.
That actually saves the planet.
You want me to say that fucking egg head,
how to do your job. He would suck at it.
People always tell me not to make me feel
better, but what his legs looked like.
Shit, he's wearing a fucking
wearing your shoes. They don't fit.
If you put them in your job,
it would be terrible at it.
You've got to realize that like everybody
has their own little station in this
life. If you really true, if you
really treat life for what it is,
it's some sort of a weird experience.
You know, it's a temporary experience.
It lasts a long time relatively in your,
you know,
like in comparison to like
holding in your pee. Yeah.
You'll life lasts a long fucking time.
But the reality of it is it slips
away pretty God damn quickly. Yeah.
And the things that we dwell on our like
these markers of like achievement and
these like measures of success
and these, you know, the our,
our ability to measure ourselves against
the other people that were competing
with or some sort of a weird way,
but all that stuff is self defeating.
W we really need to do is find some
sort of a comfortable medium where we're
actually doing what we want
to do most of the time.
And obviously what you want
to do is what you're doing.
When if you were that fucking dude and
you're doing computations till three
o'clock in the morning
on some fucking glass,
it's going to make electricity and nobody
gives a shit what your shoes look like.
You'd be like, fuck this
job. This job sucks.
I'm tired of working 16 hours a day on
fucking stupid solar glass. I'm tired.
I'm tired. I want to be a
reporter. I want to be on TV.
I want to wear cute clothes. Come on. What
the fuck? All right, fair enough. Fair.
You wouldn't be happy.
You're happy with,
I love what I do. Don't get me wrong. I
love what I do. But every once in a while,
you know, you do, you do size people up,
right? Of will. Especially
because you're an educated,
successful woman who already,
you're already a little bit a little
bit of chip on your shoulder plus your
Armenian and then you're out there in
this competitive environment where in all
fairness, I think women have to, uh,
I feel they feel at least that they have
to prove themselves maybe even 10% more
than men who are just as competent
as them just to be accepted as like,
as at that same level because
men have this idea, oh,
she just wants to get pregnant and then
she's going to take paternity leave and
she's not serious about this job.
And there's a lot of people that have
those kind of prejudices about women in
the workforce. So you all automatically
have to get gangster on people. So you're,
you're,
you're always ramped up an extra 10%.
Yeah. There's also, there's also
this notion, and I don't know,
Chris is looking at me.
Nailed it. I know, I know. I got
you. I got you. I know. What's up.
There's also like this notion that like
an attractive woman can't be smart,
like rude,
like a comment that I get often and it's
a sweet comment and I love people that
send this to me, but I think that they're
a little misguided is like, oh yeah,
beauty and brains such a rarity. And
it's like, no, it's, it's not, it's
not a rarity and I want you to be dumber
because that way they can fuck you.
They can throw their, their tricks and
their Voodoo on you and they get fuck you.
But I think a year, one of the more
intelligent podcast guests that I have,
Rhonda, Patrick [inaudible] Patrick,
every time I got damn talk to her,
I don't know half the shit she's talking
about is this doctor Rhonda Patrick
who's a found my fitness on Twitter.
She's amazing.
And she comes on the podcast like every
few months and breaks down all sorts of
different issues between new
vitamin absorption in the
last one was head trauma.
Like she schooled me on head trauma
and the issues with head trauma,
like all the things that I kind
of like had she like in depth,
described them in great detail. And
like as she's talking like my, my,
I'm just trying to just keep up at
all at this certain point in time.
So I'm just tapping out on my,
I'm going to have to go over this after
it's over and take notes cause there's
no fucking way, cause she'll
go on, he's like 10 15 minutes.
Super Complicated rants.
Like I've talked to people on Twitter
that said they listened to that podcast
seven times. They just listened to
it over and over and over again.
Like what vitamin B complex is most
important for this and what it contributes
to what vitamin D contributes
to a muscle fiber growth.
And we're going to go and she hits you
with all this different shit and it's
like whoa. And she's
beautiful. So that's nonsense.
She's way fucking smarter than me.
There's a lot of, I mean it's, it's,
there's a lot of like really good
looking guys that are smart as fuck.
And for some dudes that's annoying as
shit. He said it's beautiful, handsome,
a Donna's character and you're like
that stupid fuck. Meanwhile, he's a phd,
like Vladimir Klitschko, the fucking
heavyweight champion of the world.
He's a doctor.
He's got a fucking phd,
six,
six and shredded.
He speaks four languages and it'll fuck
you up and nobody wants to believe that
you want to take. Oh, that fucking
meathead. Always a boxer. Yeah,
I bet he's real smart. He's way smarter
than you. He plays chess every day.
All right. He's, he's a fucking
world champion boxer for like tech.
Look at that handsome bastard. That's
the heavyweight champion of the world.
Get the fuck Outta here.
He's a super athlete from the future.
That's some Russian fucking engineering
shit that doesn't even make sense.
How tall is that dude? He's
like six, six or something.
You look just like that without
your shirt on. Christian. Oh,
this place got hot and heavy.
Six six two 40 Jesus fucking Christ.
Six six to 40 with a doctorate degree.
Nobody wants to admit that they want
to big fucking mood hood. That big fit.
He's way smarter than you
and I'll fuck you up. Sorry.
But you're probably better at PAC man.
Yeah,
I'm probably better at world of Warcraft.
You've probably got a higher rating.
It doesn't. You know like,
people are weird, man. We,
everybody wants it to be a goddamn race
from beginning to end. Enjoy your life.
Everybody gets a different hand of cards.
Do whatever the fuck you can with it.
Don't get crazy because it doesn't last.
It's just have some fun.
Tried to make it the most enjoyable.
That's six foot six fucking Adonis.
He might be miserable.
What do I, what do I know?
You know you might have a wife
screams at him. Throw shit out of him.
We don't know. You don't know
what his life is like. You know,
he might have shitty taste in music.
You might have like, you know,
you might fucking be listening to
terrible music all day and you're like,
I hate him. I don't want to beat
him. We're weird. We're weird. We,
we compare like you're comparing yourself
to the solar glass people. I'm like,
thank God those egg heads are out there.
Much love to you.
Tweet something, Holler
at me. I help you out.
As long as you're doing
something you enjoy,
as long as you're surrounded by
people that you love, you got to,
you got to enjoy the moment a little bit.
Which is what he tells me all the time
with Cubans don't have to rocket. Oh yeah,
they do. They do Cuban.
That's a, that's a fun.
Like Joey Dee is my favorite human being
of all time. He's born in Cuba. He's,
he knows. They just, there's a different
flair to the Latin cultures they have.
They have more fun. Like
we're, we get more shit done.
We do, we get more shit done,
but what do you want?
Do you want to get more shit done
or do you want to have more fun?
And it becomes like this
balancing act of man.
I don't know because like you said,
like people that are the most happy in
the world. I did this some sort of a,
you know, an index of most happy
countries. Mexico was pretty fucking high.
I'm very surprised about that really was,
especially in good time,
good for them, good
for them. You know, we,
we are caught up in this idea
that unless you're keeping tabs,
unless you're numbers are ahead of their
numbers or your position or your social
caste systems ahead, then you shouldn't
be happy. But it's so stupid. Like,
you know what? You need happiness friends,
hanging around with a bunch of friends,
have a good time, do stuff that you
like. That's it. Be Nice to each other.
You'll get more friends. Be Nice to
those friends. There'll be loyal to you.
You'll be loyal to them, your brothers
and sisters. You stay together forever.
Everybody's cool. It's all you have
to do is you find a gang of friends.
He collect friends that are cool and
you enforce your love for them and they
enforce their love for you and you
shield yourself from the outside world by
forming these pockets and communities
of awesome people that can be done,
that can be done, but it can't
be done if you're fucking king.
Shit real estate mogul once a fuck over
your partners and your investors and
you're just trying to pump and dump stocks
and fuck you like the guy in wolf of
Wall Street. Like that sort of crazy
mentality. Capitalism above all costs,
like you're missing out on the
balancing act of life. You're just,
you're an asshole.
You're a guy who thinks he's gonna run
the marathon by running as fast as you
can right from the beginning. No
one's, no one's ever thought of that.
Everybody started that stupid.
You can't do that.
You can't sprint for three hours.
You fuckhead. It's not possible.
Everyone knows by now.
So when you're doing that,
what you're really doing
is you're sprinting you're
way through the beginning,
couple miles of a marathon to fucking die.
That's what you're doing.
You're treating life like a moron.
This is better than any therapy
session I've ever had. This is great.
I feel better about life.
I did too. I do too.
It's coming out of me and I feel better
about it, but that's what you know.
I mean, and everybody says like,
you know, hey me, you know,
that's easy for you or I can't afford it.
Without a doubt,
everyone has different circumstances,
but without a doubt,
every circumstances could
be managed more optimally.
Every single one that's ever existed,
we're flawed and we
learned from our mistakes,
which means everyone approaches every
single situation in their life where
you're just kind of basing it off of
the information that you've acquired,
the knowledge that you've gathered,
the experience that you've
sorta calculated in your brain,
and this is how I think,
and then if it goes fucking Shitty,
like your cop situation,
yeah, you go, well,
now I got some fucking new shit in here
and the next mother fucker the tries
that nonsense. Yeah. I'm,
I'm asking questions,
I'm writing things down and I'm making
a fucking story and I'm making a fucking
difference. That's the difference. That's
what happens with us. We grow and learn.
I mean, that's, that's
what it's all about.
Yeah. Yeah, absolutely.
There's no question about it.
I would say like the happiest
moments of my life. We're not.
When I was sitting there competing with
other people or trying to achieve more
in my career,
it was definitely moments where I traveled
somewhere with a really good friend
moments where I've, you know, shared
like a really great meal with a coworker.
Like those are the things that are more
memorable and I think that my generation
is moving away from like the
obsession of owning big things, right?
Like less people in my generation are
buying homes partly because they can't do
it because they're straddled
with student loan debt,
but also because they don't want
to be tied down to one place.
They want to go see the world, they want
to go experience things. And so, you know,
we talked about this a little bit
the first time I was on your podcast,
but sometimes I struggle with that
too, right? Sometimes I'm like, yeah,
I want to buy a big house.
And then other times I'm like looking at
my quaint little apartment and I'm like,
this is fine.
I'd rather have some money saved in the
bank to go on some cool trip and like
meet people and learn new things.
If I was Joey Diaz right now I go
on a rant about fuck that shit.
You getting paid need a fucking big crib
with pillars like Elvis had marble shit
like they had in Greece.
What the fuck you told me you gotta
keep your money in the bank and those
fucking people going to steal it on.
You get the fuck Outta here.
You want a Bentley and a fucking jet and
a helicopter and missile launchers and
a fucking pool your face on the bottom
of it. That's what Joey d is it say.
And I agree with him.
You're making a lot of money.
You should fucking spend that shit.
Fuck a one bedroom apartment.
Hello.
But yeah, you just have fun.
It's, it's hard for people to do.
Sorry people we quantify too much.
We do quantify our lives too much.
You know, question. But you know,
I think there's one thing that if I
could ever give, especially men advice,
healthy friendly competition,
that is the difference.
The real problem that people have with
competition is, is very self defeating.
And a lot of times losing at things is
insanely frustrating and it makes men
especially angry.
And this is a trap and this is a trap.
And it's essentially a non management of
a biological system that's put in place
to allow you to try to rise to the highest
possible spot and the social spectrum
for you to breed.
And it's a trick and that trick is in
place and it can fuck men up so they can
get angry at their best friends.
If they're playing pickup basketball,
they can get to a point where they want
to have fistfights over basketball and
men.
But if they didn't,
if the exact same thing happen and they
still experienced the heightened sense
of competitiveness,
but always with friendship and love
for the person you're competing with,
you can have better results.
You can have better results because
you're still gonna have that same
competitive drive, but you never
allow yourself to hate the opponent.
You waste energy. In fact,
when you hate the opponent,
I think, I mean, I don't know
if this is the same for men,
but whenever I meet a woman who's super
accomplished and I feel a little bit of
envy,
I actually just picks you turn green.
I know, right? No,
I actually use that as more
of an inspirational thing
as opposed to like, oh,
I hate her and now I'm going to like tear
her down and try to find her fault so
I could feel better about,
feel better about myself.
I love meeting really successful women
that shake me out of my complacency
because as humans we love
to be complacent. Whether
or not we are aware of it,
we kind of like slide into
that, you know, comfort zone.
And so I like it when I meet a
woman who's like smarter than me,
more successful than me and subtle
like hating on her. I'll be like,
what can I do to be like her
or better than yes. Yeah,
that's healthy. That's very healthy. And
being inspired by people that you meet,
especially people that are doing like
what you're doing for a living or what
you're doing or for a hobby or anything
that you, you know, any pursuit,
whether it money's
involved in art, um, Eh,
they can be incredibly empowering
tor or defeating and with,
with men especially men have a real
issue in denial of the actual competitive
nature of the scenario.
Like there's some men that they have
this idea of what they look like and the,
this idea of what a bad mother fucker
they are and how cool they are now front
of the Ark and the rest of the world
has a completely different opinion. Yup.
And they don't,
they don't ever allow themselves to see
what they're doing wrong because then it
chips away at this armor that they've put
on this armor being this false opinion
of themselves and they go out of their
way to make sure that's never exposed
through trial.
And that's what one of the things that
separates people who do difficult things.
Anything that's really hard to do.
I think in doing something that's very
difficult, whether it's, you know,
running fucking marathons or climbing
mountains or martial arts or anything
you're doing, it's hard to do. You learn
about your ability to push yourself.
You learn how to overcome obstacles.
You learn about yourself in a way that
people that are sort of in denial about
where their standing as far as how
good they are at anything. You know,
there's some people that think through
the shit, they don't even have a job.
But yeah, Bro, I'm shit
falls working there.
I'd be fucking running
things Balsa president ma,
but fuck off till Russia
to suck my Dick Man,
new Pabst blue ribbon gets opened.
You know,
there's a lot of people that
think they're fucking awesome,
but if you peered in on them,
you know,
if you had a window into their trailer
and you saw their fucking no dirty socks
and their foot's kicked up on the
couch, you'd be like, Oh my God,
you fucking idiot.
You don't know how the world sees you.
And for men especially,
it's like the,
the need to be little competition is
a very dangerous thing. You know, the,
the need to not be empowered by people
that are better that you see around you.
Cause when you,
when you see them and you embrace
and you have no hate in your heart,
then you can actually be empowered
and it'll actually make you better at
whatever you do.
Yeah, absolutely. You got to learn
from people around you. You know,
you got to learn from the mistakes
that people make around you.
You got to learn from the people who are
doing things that are better than what
you're doing and,
and don't,
my tendency is to feel down
about myself time to time.
I don't end up hating the
person who's better than me.
I start like being very critical,
overly critical of myself.
Like don't let that happen either because
that's very destructive. Yeah. Um,
but yeah,
like I'm lucky that I work in a field
where I'm exposed to super intelligent
people on a regular basis. Like, you know,
I don't agree with everything
that Jank says. Uh,
we have differences of
opinion in a lot of it.
They think that and I'm going to edit it
and I'm going to send it to them right
now,
motherfucker.
Um, but Genx, my mentor, you know,
I learned a lot from him and I'm so
grateful that I was able to like grow next
to him and learn a lot of stuff.
And he also built a company that
expanded to the point where we're,
we have a steady flow of intelligent
people coming in all the time.
We have these great conversations. I'm
always learning new things. I love that.
I have a job where I get to learn
new things. You get that too.
And it's awesome where you know,
you guys have a dope office to you.
Like this is a corporation.
You guys are a corporation,
you have a fucking staff dude.
It wasn't always like that or workstations
and everyone's friendly though.
It's very nice people super fast with
you by the way, when you came in.
Not like in a creepy way.
Um,
so I'm going to give him a shout out
because he's a big fan and he's like,
well listening right now.
Um,
how Hassan who's actually genx nephew
is like such a big fan of yours.
And he was like, oh, Joe, Joe's going
to be at the Improv. Like I gotta go,
I gotta go see Joe.
And then I noticed that like as soon as
he saw you walking through the studio,
he wanted to take a picture with you.
And I was like, oh my God, how's,
you're so embarrassing.
Please stop.
Oh, that's all right. He's a person
so it doesn't embarrass me. It's fine.
So shout out to Hassan. Yes. No, you
guys have like a real corporation.
Like you go in there, it feels like you
know what you're doing. You go in here.
If Jamie died, I'd be fucked.
Bring Brian in here every day.
Be a disaster again.
Huh?
Okay. How is Brian? He
doesn't, he's not here yet.
Well, if sums podcasts, he
doesn't do it. Oh, I see.
He does ones that I feel like he
would be best suited for. I see.
I see. Okay. If that
makes sense. I think too,
you can only do so many podcasts with
the same person over and over again.
You know, I think, I think, uh,
one of the things about doing
podcasts is you've got to do what?
Like you gotta talk to the people you
want to talk to have the conference.
You've got to do it
when you want to do it.
Like that's the whole idea behind
it to me is that, you know,
there is no set schedule.
There is no employer that's telling me
what I can and can't talk about gas than
I'm being forced to interview. Right.
That's the worst. That's the worst. Yeah.
The cool thing about it too is that
it's now podcasting has become something
that people are willing to do.
Like I had Paul Stanley from kiss
on this this year and I was like,
you gotta get the Fuck Outta here.
I can't believe I got Paul Stanley
sitting here. I was such a little fan boy.
Yeah.
Such a little fan with Joe Perry,
Joe Perry's my friend Joe
Perry from Aerosmith. I'm like,
this is my friend Joe Perry.
You have to give yourself some credit
though because you do a three hour long
podcast in the middle of nowhere La wise.
It's not hard to do.
It's not, it's not. But it's intimidating
if you haven't done it before.
So before I came into the first podcast
with you, I was definitely nervous.
I'm like, oh my God, three hours.
Like what are we going to talk about
for three freaking hours straight,
no breaks, no nothing. Right? Um, so
the fact that you know, these big name,
people are willing, not
me, but like, uh, you know,
the people you mentioned earlier are
willing to come in and sit down with you
for three hours. That that means that
you've, you've made it my friend.
I don't even know what that means,
but it's pretty cool to be able to
talk to Rosanne bar for three hours.
Roseanne Barr isn't awesome.
Roseanne,
Paul has given me a hard time the other
day because we had this show on. And uh,
there was uh, no chicks and the show
and I said that I secretly, she goes,
what the hell? No women on the show
at all. Question Mark. And I said,
I secretly made no women on the show,
just cause I knew you would complain.
Success, that's fine.
And then she said, well,
you know something to the lines of,
you're on the show that I guess a
chick is on the show. And I said, well,
if you're calling me a chicken, you're a
check. That's a compliment. She's great.
She's awesome. She's so crazy.
She is. She's in my opinion,
one of the all time great comics.
Like she doesn't get a,
and I told her that when she was in the
studio, like if I had a list of 10 time,
uh, you know, top 10, like mo most
important comics in my opinion,
she,
she became a totally unique and new thing.
Like when she burst onto the scene,
she was like murder in it
and doing these HBO specials,
they had never been a woman like her
before telling men to suck it shot up.
You know, she had this like fucking
attitude with good joke writing.
Like that attitude plus good
joke writing and a genuine,
not give a fuck outlook on things.
Yeah. And now when she talks,
it was really funny because she talks
about her life. She's super honest,
but I'll crazy and off the rails.
She was awesome.
She's the best.
A really good friend of mine,
Dave Ruben,
who also does a show for our network is
very good friends with Roseanne and she
apparently has like a TV studio like that.
She built herself and he's now like doing
some shows like out of her TV studio.
Um, and like I've heard stories about how
freaking awesome she is and I love it.
I love how open she is and I don't know,
she's a lot of,
I've met her a few times too.
She's great.
She's out. And she also
is not dogmatic, you know,
she had this idea about chem trails all,
they're spraying things in the sky,
you know, and I, and we
had this conversation about
it and I said that's not,
they're not really doing that.
That's not what's happening.
I'll tell you exactly what's happening.
Cause we investigated it and there's
a lot of people to believe that,
but they really haven't looked into it.
It's scientifically been proven that
when a jet engine goes through the
atmosphere, it was a certain temperature
and a certain amount of condensation.
It actually produces artificial clouds.
Yeah.
It's a very scientific
principle behind it.
It's really easy to understand and
you see it explained and go, oh,
that's what it is. And so
they're always like, well,
why is it always in grid pattern? Like
I had a guy on the podcast and like us,
that's what flights do. They go the same
way every day. It's a flight pattern.
You think planes just take off
like a boat out in the ocean.
Just any fucking path they want. You
know, like you've got to fucking sailboat.
You just left and right.
No,
you don't have to go exactly where they
tell you to otherwise just slamming each
other. You fuck, you know, like
so, but when I told her this,
she sort of went, oh, okay.
Like she, like she didn't,
she didn't get crazy red in the face.
Right.
I heard that is such an admirable
quality in people because when someone's
pointing to something you just said and
they were like, no, it's actually wrong.
Here's what the reality is. I mean,
I think the human and, and you know,
understandable reaction is to
like try to defend yourself. Yeah.
Even though you know you're wrong and
it's like the best feeling when you
finally just like recognize
like, oh, I'm wrong.
I'm just going to admit that I'm wrong
and an do more research into it and
figure it out. You know what I mean? I
think that's more admirable than like, no,
I'm gonna defend myself.
Even though you have evidence proving
that what I've just said is bullshit.
Well, I think people are learning
now in this day and age that it's,
there's really no benefit in
pretending you're never wrong. Yeah.
Especially when it comes to
things that are like you.
No one has all the information.
Exactly. You can't.
There's too much going on in the world.
You know everything about aviation
do everything about viruses.
You know everything about computer codes.
You know everything about Portuguese.
You can't, there's too much shit. You
don't have enough time in the day. Yeah.
So you might have a
misconception in your mind,
doesn't mean you're a fucking idiot.
It means you were wrong.
You're a fucking idiot if
you continue to cling to it,
even while it's being explained
to you that it's not correct.
That's what makes you a fucking idiot.
And unfortunately, especially for men,
again,
we cling to ideas.
We don't want to ever say we were wrong
because then we give up this position of
being smarter. Right? This position
of being better or winning.
Yeah. I, Kevin Pereira said something
to me that I loved and it's so true.
He's like, what's wrong with saying I
don't know, time to time. So you know,
and and it's true.
Like there's like this fear,
especially when you do an interview with
someone or when you come on a podcast
that someone's going to ask you something
that you don't know the answer to and
then you have to utter the words.
I don't know because you're going to
get criticism for it, but like why?
It's not like I know everything
that there is to know. That's crazy.
Those two percents out there
counting it up. That's what it is.
Those are the ones who are
going to complain because
those are the ones who are
not going to know. Of course, you
can't know everything. She goes,
I can't believe you.
Just know what the Balton island.
Just always going to be someone
he's going to be that problem.
And you know there's,
there's a lot of people that are out
there and they pretend that this never
comes up in their life.
Why don't you just talk about
things and I'm not aware of,
of course you do stupid,
have a contact,
have a conversation with
someone you don't know.
You just start talking to you about
some shit you don't know about.
You know someone from somewhere else.
So it's a different kind of life.
You couldn't possibly know what they know.
Exactly.
No one can know everything and
it doesn't mean you're dumb.
And that's the problem is that in small
social circles or especially where the
instinct probably comes
from tribal situations,
you all have access to
the same amount of data.
The one who knows more is
the one who's more wise.
It was the one who paid more attention
or the one who has more experience or
more success.
So that man becomes preferable.
And so when you're in an open environment
like earth in 2000 and almost 15 you
can't do that anymore. That's stupid.
There's too much shit out there.
Like the amount of data is
unprocessable when it's about, oh,
don't eat that yellow leaf because
it gives you diarrhea. You know,
you eat the green leaf and
you're dead in 15 minutes.
Like you got to know that
stuff or are you going to,
you're a dumb ass out in the jungle and
you're going to die. Right, exactly.
But that's a finite amount of
shit. You know, there's the,
it's just about like what fish will kill
you if it bites your Dick, you know,
like this, you don't, you, you know,
the amount of data that
you have to process being a
human with a computer today,
it's unsurmountable
on, it really is. It really is. So there's
no shame in saying, I don't know. In fact,
I, I trust people more when
they say, I don't know.
Because the worst thing is when you
have someone in the media who has no
freaking idea what they're talking about
and they're just bullshitting their way
through an interview or bull,
you know, like, you know,
Sarah Pailin wasn't so good at
bullshitting her way through it.
But instead of saying,
I don't know,
her dumb ass tried to answer questions
and like the most ignorant way possible.
Well she got busted the the whole thing.
The can of worms opened up with
that Katie Kirk, that was so,
it turned out that she has read anything
but like so obvious. Oh you know,
you know as a shit.
I read newspapers,
I'm reading fortune cookies and stuff.
I checked a Chinaman.
She just decided to just go on that with
no preparation and just charm her way
through it. I bet you thought it
was just going to be all softballs,
but that's the thing a lot of,
first of all,
a lot of the questions were soft ball.
I mean how about this,
do you think that that same approach
would have ever been done if it was a man?
Do you think that a man from Alaska would
be asked what books he reads or what
newspapers he subscribes to?
I bet they wouldn't.
Well, I think that honestly
with the way the interview went,
it started off with respectable question,
respectful questions. It wasn't,
it wasn't like a gender thing at
all. Like, Oh, you're a woman,
so I'm going to softball you.
I think that Katie realize that this woman
has no idea what she's talking about.
And so her follow up questions were super
tame, you know, kind of like, all right,
we'll do you read news?
Yeah.
It never got really confrontational
the way maybe you would do it right?
I mean you would go after. Yeah, I think.
I would think so too. Um, I remember
one when I was at, but I think
Katie was probably setting her up.
She's probably had given her some
soft jabs. Yeah. Waiting to drop that.
What do you read bitch playing?
You know,
think they researched and found out that
chick doesn't read anything. I probably,
they probably did. I actually, I think
that Katie Couric was tactful. She,
she handled it. Jamie agrees. Yeah.
Sat her up big right hand. She,
what do you read bitch? Plam
the knees go, eyes rolled back.
She plus,
well Harold is a little bit of that
like Katie's thing and I could be the
fucking president too. Wow.
Think about that for a second.
Think about how that woman almost became
the vice president of the United States.
SORTA. Kinda. Yeah. It would've been fun.
Just like Dan Quayle who
do the same type of shit,
Mccain's still alive look
all these whoa through.
So she wouldn't really have any influence,
but maybe though the job might have
killed him cause we don't know what Obama
really would have looked like
if he never got that Gig.
I mean he might've all black hair right
now. Could you imagine that? Yeah.
He looked like pretty similar to
the way he looks six years ago.
I mean he aged so much in six years.
We'll do about how terrible this job.
I would never want to be
president of the youth.
I wouldn't want to be a politician,
period. It sounds like it.
Terrible job.
It almost sounds like an incredibly flawed
system that is taking part in in the
where it's like almost like the answer
trying to rebuild the ant colony while
they're carrying leaves in like, guys,
we've got to make new tunnels. Fuck off.
Carry this. Yeah. How are you going
to fix this gigantic ant colony?
You're not going to fix that.
It's a great analogy. I love that,
but isn't it like that kind of,
in a way it's like you,
even if you're the president,
even if you're the one person that gets
to talk to Congress and you have debate
and you do speeches and all this different
there, the reality is, Mike, God would,
a machine is behind this fucking world.
Oh my God. How many influences my God,
how much money,
my God,
how much long standing patterns of
behavior that are very difficult to change
like a lobbyists.
But if somebody tried to propose lobbyists
today in the age of the Internet,
if like there was no lobbyists and they
tried to come along and propose a lot of
people like get the fuck out,
100% what are you talking about?
100% if the Internet got to vote on
whether or not Congress would allow
corporations to donate money like
an individual, they would go,
are you fucking crazy? Why
would we do that? Why would
we do that? Why would it be?
What's the benefit? Dirtier rivers like
what? What's the benefit there? What's,
what's, what's going to come
out of that. That's good.
I know. It's crazy. Yeah.
The system is definitely set up against
us and the entire notion of a democratic
process.
You can't have a democratic process when
you have corporations giving unlimited
amounts of money to politicians.
It's just not going to happen.
There's no competition. You
know, this is, this blew my mind,
although I've done this type of reporting
for so long, it shouldn't surprise me.
During the midterm elections,
the Koch Brothers spent between 275 no,
225 and $300 million.
I mean,
let's just go to the lower end of that
$225 million to influence the midterm
elections. So crazy. It's, it's so much
money.
It's so much money.
I love that they're called the Koch
brothers too. I hope they do a lot of it.
I hope they do it in their underwear
while they're getting their toes. Dot.
You know, they just are just constantly
getting massaged and eaten grapes.
People dangled grapes over there.
Very sure they, I mean, I always wonder
brothers I live in like gangsters.
How much money do you need?
How much freaking money do you know?
Well obviously you don't need that
225 million just gives those stupid
politicians and the politicians eat it up.
They have to do is well yeah
how much money do you need?
And but I think it's also
their professional players
of the game that has made
them incredibly successful.
Yup.
They're the baddest motherfucking
monopoly players on earth. You know,
they figured out a way to
do it at a very high stakes.
I'm sure it's insanely addictive.
They don't want to let it go. No, I'm sure
it is addictive as well. And you know,
first of all they're terrible people so
don't think that I'm excusing them but
dare you.
But I will also say,
I will also say that if the
system is set up as such,
why wouldn't you take advantage of it?
Because you're nice cause your ethical
cause you realize you're a temporary life
forms sharing time with these other people
and she'd tried to make the world the
best possible. You have the best possible
influence on it that you can. Yeah.
That's not the best possible influence
on it and it's not the best beneficial if
fill it for you.
It's not that beneficial because
you've already reached this point of
diminishing returns where you got
enough money to donate $225 million.
Whoa.
Do you like fly fishing?
Because you should do that with
your day. If you could. You imagine,
I would never even think about
working in a bank if I had,
if I had enough money where I could
give someone $225 million to, you know,
fix whatever fucking laws or make it
so yeah. You know, whatever the fuck.
Damn again, still sit in my favor.
My God. I would be, I would,
I would be like tuna fishing.
I would get a jet ski that goes a hundred
miles an hour. It'd be having fun.
Why would you,
why would you want to be involved?
You're like 80 what are you doing?
How much more money can you like enjoy?
I don't understand it at all.
I mean,
what's the point of building this kind
of wealth if you don't actually use it?
And I'm sure they enjoy it in some ways,
but they also spend a sizable chunk
of their lives destroying the country.
I think there's also a momentum behind it,
like a successful mantram almost
akin to what you were describing.
When you see other people that are
more successful and even though you get
inspired by it,
some people may not like that thing that
drives you to worry about your success
level, which is very high for,
would you say you're 28 yeah,
very high for 28 year old woman.
You've been on a very successful
new show for many years now.
You're very respected. You do these
conversations with people online.
They're very well received,
but yet you still will trip about like
what you've done and what you haven't
done well. I guess when you're like
a super fucking crazy billionaire,
maybe you want to be like Dracula
or some of them, you know?
Maybe you want to have a hoard of slaves
that bow before you and you're just
waiting for you to have enough money to
buy some technology that turns the world
and the fucking goblins that are
at your command or something.
I don't fucking know. I'm not exactly
sure if I get that kind of motivation.
You know, like $100 billion
motivation or toward 10 billion.
All your woe to doing.
What'd you doing? I don't know. I don't
understand it either. And you know,
like earlier in the show I talked about
how I questioned whether or not people
are inherently good.
And you know what?
I think a lot of people are inherently
good and we've turned you around. You,
you have this was,
this has been a very productive podcast.
The one thing that I will say is I get
a lot of pleasure out of giving back to
my community because
growing up here in la,
there were so many things that were
provided to me as someone who was kind of
disadvantaged because like growing up,
my parents weren't wealthy. You know,
my parents were struggling,
they were working class.
And I had a great public
education. I had, you know,
access to something
called healthy families,
which was like an affordable form
of health insurance for kids.
Like all of these things were
paid for by tax payers. Right.
And these are the things that helped me
build a life for myself and helped me
become successful.
And I feel like it's my obligation to
give back to the community and help in any
way that I can.
Cause I want to see people who are maybe
from a poor neighborhood grow up and be
able to do what they really want
to do with their lives. You know,
I'm living my dream right now.
I want to make sure other
people have that same ability.
That's beautiful.
I think it's really cool that you do that
and I think it's really cool that you
teach that in journalism course
too, because I love it. Yeah,
it's cool that you're doing it and you're
like someone who's actually out there
doing it as a Gig,
you know?
And then you're teaching people
how to do it and do it correctly.
That's about it. Yeah, it's great.
That cast Berrien, we're at a time,
we just sit three hours
sane so fast by five by,
if I didn't have to pee so hard it would
have been like the last 10 minutes I'm
hanging in there, but uh, okay.
Uh, Twitter and a CAS baron.
Is there anything you would like to
promote or tell me what you got coming up?
So I have a personal youtube channel.
I post a lot of stuff on there.
It's youtube.com/ana a Berrien. So check
me out there. And Instagram and a cast.
Barry and TYT.
Beautiful. Thank you. It was
always fine. I had a great time.
I had a great time doing your show too. It
was really fun. Oh, oh. All right folks.
That's it for now. Uh, we will be back
next week. A lot of fun guests are,
can't tell you who it's some secret shit,
but, uh, we got some good ones. All right.
So enjoy your weekend or whenever
the fuck you're listening to this.
And much love. Big Kiss
Mom, mom, mom, my mom.
Bye.
Hmm.
Okay.